oui je vends soir à tous et bienvenue
pour cette première demi-finale de ce
pitch est ce qui oppose arica à barika à
daha danielian donc la joueuse
arménienne à la joueuse indienne désolé
jeu buggé un petit peu parce que je suis
en train de me poser une question par
rapport au stream si j'étais bien en
route et qui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec les homos et en même temps je fais
buggé les filles c'est magnifique
l'échec est devenu microscopique on va
le remettre bien je les ai bien que
j'avais eu un petit bug a mis les îles à
l'envers du coup oulala c'est marrant ça
on a réussi à le mettre à l'envers salut
oui petit c'est drôle ça attendra le
remettre à l'endroit
non il est encore plus à l'envers
qu'avant il est toujours à l'envers il
est toujours à l'envers c'est après un
fois que ça m'arrive voire un échec à
l'envers j'ai fait passer le truc à
l'envers je sais plus comment le mettre
à l'endroit c'est impressionnant
bon c'est un moment rare en afrique sur
le mauvais truc
ce sera la première fois que ça m'arrive
du coup et donc est là c'est pas mal
réussi à leur faire passer à l'endroit
c'était marrant de toute façon tu sais
même pas cet endroit là quand on a
besoin donc le match qu'on va suivre ce
soir c'est le match dont deux demi
finales de speechless féminin vous avez
le tableau désole un j'ai eu ce petit
bug qui fait que qui fait qu'il ya tout
qui bug mais ça va revenir donc
j'attends une petite seconde vems
entendre juste j'ai le j'ai le choix des
fenêtres sur obs qui est complètement
pls et ça pouvait pas en être autrement
parce que c'est le dernier stream que je
fais deux
filles l'appartement dans lequel je suis
à présent et donc ça ne pouvait en être
autrement
çà çà çà devait buggé pour la dernière
c'était obligatoire je sais pas si vous
voyez encore en tout cas je l'espère il
va falloir que je trouve les joueuses
maintenant et il ne pouvait en être
autrement eh oui je peux pas les trouver
parce que hadji obs qui a complètement
buggé la bon je suis obligé d'attendre
tu peux je ne touche à rien je vois ma
tête bouger mais au-delà de ça je peux
pas faire grand chose mis à part
attendre alors je vais pas être obligé
de relancer le stream ce serait bien la
première fois que ça arrive mais bon il
faut une première à tout bon je pense ça
va se remettre tout seul
déjà si vous me voyez c'est pas mal ça
arrive dans les bacs de toute façon mais
là c'est un peu spécial comme bugs
j'ai tout le reste qui marche donc c'est
la bonne nouvelle
il va falloir que je trouve les joueuses
or qu'est-ce qu'elles ont comme ceux
déjà arica c'est pas à renoncer pas à
arica tout à fait faux frais que je
réussisse à voir l'image du live bon ok
le bug est passé donc ce que je valais
c'est joli sur cette image
ok on va on va lancer le truc bien comme
il faut on devrait avoir voit le tableau
qui s'ouvre ça c'est bien
on va avoir un tout petit peu de retard
et est en fait c'est ce que quelqu'un le
pseudo des joueuses est-ce qu'elle joue
parce que quelqu'un dans le chat est
capable de me choper ça ouais c'est les
aléas du direct à un petit bug pour
finir c'est pas plus mal
comme je vous dis fallait bien que ça
arrive un jour ou l'autre c'est
l'impression qu'elles sont en train est
ce qu'elles sont en train de jouer ou
pas tak tak façon la cadence et 5 + 2
donc je verrai automatiquement
il ya peut-être un bug dans le titre
c'est possible aussi je vais vérifier ça
fait ce que je peux faire pour trouver
c'est parti pour eux et je vais réussir
à choper les pseudo on va on va mettre
élégance rixe
ah oui voilà c'est ça cette élégance
rixe alors on va suivre ça j'ai checké
le bug sur le titre on va suivre
élégance rixe voilà ça c'est bon déjà la
partie est lancée
et en ce qui concerne le bug sur le
titre on va réussir aussi peut-être à
régler ça et au moins on sera tranquille
une bonne fois pour toute façon on a le
temps arias 3h30 de deux jeux à venir
donc j'ai envie de dire on est on est
passé pas c'est pas là que ça va jouer
face c'est aussi là que ça va jouer bien
sûr mais ok rien il ya une faute de
frappe sur le titre il ya une faute de
frappe sur le titre c'est exact et une
faute de frappe sur le titre je fais
régler ça tout de suite
salut nkt à mon soir à toi on va tout de
suite voir allez on va faire ça on va
changer donc comme ça on va être bien
bien comme il faut
fautes de frappe et le cas et le machin
sont à côté est ok donc on a une
structure de pions type eto'o de marc
auxi avec les pions eu quatre essais 4
face à hull 6 des six est donc elle va
pas pouvoir jouer
elle va pouvoir jouer ces petites karo
kann compte comme contre l'agglo salua
binck os 3 donc c'est c1 et audemars
occident on a le cul en c4 epyon 4 qui
bloquent des 5 et qui bloque b5 et on
peut même jouer parfois avec à 4 or là
c'est peut-être pas pressé encore
puisque b5 et pas vraiment une menace on
va pouvoir prendre prendre et reprendre
tout va faire tourner l on peut avoir
envie de jouer avec les blancs avec à
quatre avec les pions à 4 c 4 e4 est
complètement bloqué les pouces et b5 et
d5 et joue à long terme sur le pion des
six avec les noirs on veut jouer des
cinq coups b5 quand même à un moment
donné
tout en sachant que le pion des six est
faible mais il est pas si simple que ça
de l'attaqué et de et de lui mettre la
pression d'avoir joué tous rêvent des
huîtres ou 1,8 le puis on va être bien
tenu solidement cd et audemars auxi mais
cosy c'est quoi ton fou quand tu fais f3
maintenant fait pas grand chose en fait
de sous pour te dire la vérité se fout
il est un peu il a un peu en pls mai
mais bon il empêche b5 clés sur la dans
cette position à ce foutu peut pas en
faire grand chose
tu peux un jour peut-être faire f 4 x 3
mais souvent laisse là et on essaye
petit à petit préparer fouet 4 et 2 et
d'attaquer petit à petit des six en gros
mais ce fou et se fout eu deux masses et
mauvais fout des blancs ne vont comme je
disais il empêche quand même b5 et là il
faut voir est ce qu'on peut jouer b5
avec les noirs je pense parce que prise
prise à le faire cavalier prend et
l'idée c'est que t'as pas le temps
d'intervenir deux fois sur b5 parce
qu'il ya le échange de dames qui arrive
en premier donc d'amd de il faut dire
quand même que ça empêche b5 ça ça vient
neutraliser la dame noire donc dam des
deux dames c'est 7 avec la dame on sait
c'est ton menace plus vraiment ce
dessein parce que plus on prend plus on
prend qui est prend b5 de toute façon y
aura toujours une découverte
donc est ce que les blancs et donc ils
font b3 elle consolide ce qu'à un moment
donné aussi tu peux avoir l'idée
vraiment jouer fouet f4 pour venir
attaquer le pion que si les noirs font
eux 5 tu reviendras 11,3 et aura gagné
la casse des cinq donc les blancs qui
vont jouer x 4 toyota risque b3 et
taissy obligatoire que ça ne s'est pas
donc au caire aux achats ont pour le
moment les blancs qui sont solides
un même un plan qui peut parfois exister
c'est jouer avec g4 g5 pour chasser le
cavalier prendre de l'espace ici mais
faut faire gaffe quand on commence à
jouer avec g4 g5 puisqu'on peut se faire
contrer avec des dessins ravageur qui
même au prix d'un pion permettent
d'ouvrir le roi blanc donc elle fait le
plan que j'ai dit un tour des huîtres ou
1,8
c'est bien bien solide comme il faut là
ça prépare tête j'ai trois fous j'ai 2
f4 éventuellement attention de pas
laissées du conte rejouer avec b5
mais la dame en f2 menacé foulée six
cavaliers à cadre ok - joue pour la
casse b6 assez bien joué de la part
d'arica au taquet et bsi c'est un vrai
coup un ca attaquerez la tour est sûre
qu'elle prend dame prend car elle et ses
cinq alors ça propose de faire un
changement de structure qui remettrait
une structure de type symétrique mais
c'est bien évidemment refusée par les
blancs qui veulent vraiment insister sur
le pion des six qui est 17 leur tour et
peut-être maintenant il faut que les
blancs réussissent à augmenter la
pression
un petit peu comme dans le match contre
l'as haguenau
danielian qui avait joué très solide qui
avait eu des positions un petit peu
inférieur mais qui avait jamais craqué
elle est vraiment forte un tactiquement
elle aura pas grand chose c'est vraiment
une joueuse redoutable très caricaturaux
assez bien et a l'air d'être assez bien
adapté à la 2d aussi elle joue bien sûr
sur internet alors cette histoire de
données 3d un sable c'est plus une
question de pratique je pense les
joueurs qui ont vraiment l'habitude de
beaucoup jouer sur internet ont
forcément un avantage par rapport aux
autres c'est pas le fait que les autres
ne s'habituerait pas mais c'est juste
que si vous jouez
si vous jouez tous les jours sur
internet et claude joue deux fois par an
forcément ça fait quand même une
différence
vous n'êtes plus habitué au jeu au
rythme quoi dame g3 quand même
intéressant parce que sa menace vous
prend h six cavaliers g600 pêche et a
pas fou prend des six est assez protégé
donc elle revient avec fougue 3 est
maintenant à mon avis elle veut dame f2
et y aura plus qu'à y décède donc on
peut aller sur quatre lieux saints cafu
prend 1,6 donc elle pose une vraie
question au noir
je suis plutôt pour la joueuse indienne
moi personnellement mais bon voilà c'est
rien c'est un choix personnel
donc quel c3 et donc elle veut peut-être
fait refouler six dames h5 jouer camaïeu
deux truites je suis prêt à temps de
redif sur la chaîne en ce moment je
parle pour toi tu parles tweet which n'y
a pas spécialement plus d'heureux disent
que d'habitude
donc elle veut fou b6 éventuellement
bref j'avoue yaris qu'elle peut en faire
mais cette dame parce que c'est vrai que
si on fait fou b6 fait en gros on peut
contrôler beaucoup de casas enfin en
gros la dame elle a pas trop de casse de
repli sur la 5ème session peut faire f 4
fois f3 fourbe et six cavaliers g1 on
peut carrément couvrir absolument toutes
les cases de la dame
ces fragments pour ça qu'elle joutes des
cinq maintenant ok mais la tête assure
céder à tout repenser intermédiaire fou
prend c'est un pion prend des 5
ok pour le moment ça va foot b6 d'un
terme contre intermédiaire donc tour
quelque part leur tour 17
apparemment tour 17
j'apprends tout reprendre reprend et
elle veut tour c'est 8
voilà c'est ça pour attaquer la roi
bouge
et alors comment progresser avec les
blancs là là elle a fait plus ou moins
tout ce qu'il fallait mais les noirs
résiste mais c'est un petit peu comme
dans le calme dans le match précédent à
jose arménienne qui tient bien dans les
positions difficiles avait vraiment
vraiment très solide dans les mauvaises
positions elle réussit à bien à bien
tenir une nouvelle fois elle était mal
aller toujours mal mais elle réussit à
mettre de la résistance y'a pas de gain
direct parce que la sueur roigé de il ya
peut-être une contre attaque avec tours
d2 qui contre bien ça c'est vrai que
c'est un problème le ton retour retour
ici et ça menacera de prendre en e2 donc
il se peut qu'elles soient forcés de
faire un coup comme fouet fin ou dame f1
et dans ce cas là les noirs qui auront
résisté qu'elle fût f1
tours d2 à yap à tour c'est un cause de
dames français inquiets français à
tourcoing f de foot pro f de hockey
alors tour c1 ça marche ou pas ok ça
marche at quoi ça peut échanger
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se passe dans la
partie et une nouvelle fois la joueuse
arménienne qui un peu comme dans le
premier match et ultra ultra ultra ultra
solide dans les positions inférieures
elles les joue vraiment très bien
et ouais voilà c'est tout à son honneur
on tout bien tout honneur alors est
toujours un peu mal autant elle est
toujours mal autant mai mais elle a tenu
à la la tenue en tout bien tout honneur
c'est là peut-être g4 maintenant au
kenya puis on prend pions pour enfouir
quatre fous de mieux que foucades
j'imagine ellaroys f2 on va échanger ça
va faire nul n'y a rien à faire
ok peut-être les bourses microscopique
plus parce qu'ils font roi ici en
premier mais bon c'est rien de spécial
un ace que non mais faut être quatre tu
vas pas t'embêter non c'est juste nul
c'est juste nul mais comme comme comme
dans le premier match
danielian solide qui tient quand elle
est moins bien et quand même 2006 sur
czech comme est qui et qui réussit et
qui réussit à prendre des demi point et
c'est vrai qu'elle avait rendu à agra
mis en grosse difficulté l'agglo qui
avait fini par craquer
donc 1,3 à voir ces trois ces petits
systèmes non la jarre en cavalier évoqué
sur kei c6 peut-être qu'avec cavaliers
ou cinq peut-être ici parce que si tu
laisses faire re 5 avec les noirs ils
égalisent complètement donc ici je pense
qu'à y ces cinq bons coups avec soi
l'idée de jouer avec f4 à non là c'est
déjà trop tard qu'ils avaient lieu 5
c'était au coude avant pardon c'était
ici cavaliers 5 avec l'idée
d'éventuellement jouer avec 4,4 ou quoi
le problème
pardon c'est que là elle s est déjà trop
tard 5 arrive au suivant et les noirs
égalise voire même dans une position
plus agréable elle ses plans tout y est
pas de chance un pas de chance
pas de chance la hausse inquiète elle
s'est plantée dans l'ouverture et c'est
serré que c'est au nom puisqu'elle est
elle prend beaucoup de temps dans
l'ouverture après quand elle joue vite à
la fin d'année l'heure il fait plus
d'erreurs est vraiment fort tanzanite
note charles je viens souvent des
solutions comme ça avec les blancs vice
devient une position comme ça avec les
blancs et tout le système de londres un
conseil arrête parce que ça c'est juste
dégueulasse quand avec les blancs pas ok
c'était pas moins bien mais tu te fait
égaliser juste sans raison enfin tu
aurais pu tu peux tenter cavaliers 5 qui
est joué pour être un peu mieux si tu
joues pour jouer ça ça c'est juste égal
faille à rien ben on peut juste faire
foucher cas tour des huit se développer
et ces femmes c'est juste rien mais non
on n'a pas su avec switch youtube des
parodies ce qu'ils pensent avec les
rediffusions je parle pas je pars quoi
ici ces choses là pensez peut-être que
serait tabou statham bruce pas tabou
entoure ces huit ok tu veux pousser
peut-être un jour tu as majorité avec
a6b 5 c 4 tours des 8es attaqué quoi
trop des huit hockey et à des mises et
de quais prend 2,3 et machin qu'est f3
alors il n'y a pas une idée reprise
prise prise prise échec roi l' échec roi
là et on a un peu court on peut pas
faire mieux que nul et tour des cinq
peut-être pour essayer de faire quelque
chose
j'avais envie de sacrifier
quel bon
x 5 qu'elle va échanger non mais je joue
bien en deçà elle joue elle joue ça ce
qui est près d'alger 3 tours dessin
wilshere ça paraissait vraiment fort
cette idée de prendre de reprendre f3
prendre g3 perso je l'aurais tanti bobby
fischer ii en partie parce que le truc
c'est que dame j'ai trois belges 3 c'est
bien et pour répondre à jojo quidam g2
protège tout j'ai envie de te dire faux
parce que alors d'alger de protège tous
alors oui qui protège tous mais tu
protèges surtout le foot est roi voilà
ça faut le savoir
moi j'aurais tenté en partie ce que je
leur ai dit ok au thiery à perpète
hockey au mieux il ya tour des cinq qui
marche
et ouais j'aurais fait ça thème pour en
fait plus ou moins à prévoir quoi tu
fais tu peux faire tour des 5 es tu vois
c'était pas très dur à voir quand même
un bon mais ce fichage féminin à spa
speech and junior c'est le sait la ligne
écho plus des speechs s c'est vraiment
plus c'est d'aligner que puiser speech s
alors dame ces quatre têtes dame b 2
peut être intéressant mais mon tour a
pas grand chose qui est g5 1 en position
est également les mecs
ouais je pense qu'elle est étroite et
zap g3 et ça donnait vraiment très envie
mais bon après après sur des saints qui
est peut-être quelque chose d'un truc
c'est que si tu tentes à la nul en poche
donc en blitz et bien ces trucs là où tu
as là nul en poche échanges autour des 8
ça va refaire une nul insipide en début
de match
quoique wen ont cessé vers nulle c'est
encore un peu mieux pour les noirs fait
encore un peu mieux pour les noirs qui
auront plus de facilité à créer un pion
passer sans être non plus très grave
sans être non plus très grave mais ça va
tu mettras tadam là et tu as essayé de
pousser le pion c'est au tour des trois
qui est pas idiot comme ça si ça les
changera la donne directement des trois
c'est assez bien joué
dan m6 qui menace prise prises et
d'amanda me prends à 3 du coup à 4
empêche
ici jamais cessé danielian cas ce style
joueuse très solide qui résistent bien
qu'ils jouent beaucoup de positions
insipide
vous proposez d'un maître caché ce
problème de f4 buysscheure c'était dame
un échec est ronde et 3 je crois donc ça
échange d'1 me 6 f3
bon ce jeu pour rien que les noirs foutu
réussir et allaman bessette peut-être
faire a6b 5 après matelas d'avancé si ce
faire ces quatre là monza pas mener bien
loin et dams est ce qu'elle ne plus tôt
les noirs enfin quoique après d'amd 5
maintenant est ce que c'est vraiment
plus tôt les noirs qui presse ou quoi je
pense pas
mais peut-être un petit damage quatre
échecs ça mange pas de pain sur wave 3
dames 1
ça a l'air d'aller un maroilles 7,3 chez
vuitton madame 8 et dames 5
ok ça à faire perpète
ça va faire un nul et donc deux parties
deux nuls pour le moment c'est plutôt
africains qui a dominé un an les deux
parties mais mais bon j'ai déjà vu cette
danielian quand même très très solide un
an dans le dans le match précédent
vraiment et position compliquée elle est
vraiment très solide
ok c'est de vente accueil des sacs va
déjà vu des vidéos sur la chaîne je vous
avais que l'on appelle déjà plus comment
ça se joue avec les avec les noirs c'est
pas mon répertoire du tout donc vous ces
cinq rock pour 8 ok pourquoi pas
satisfait un coup comme détroit
préparez-vous g5 26 des quatre est
intéressant je pensais à des quatre
caisses rouges et 5 après toi genre sur
un truc comme ça moi admettons menace
est là et prendra prend des cats avec la
dame peut-être genre sur foule essaie de
prendre là et si je veux pour l'
avantage mais je sais pas un c'est ça me
paraissait bizarre
donc à trois tours b 1 elle va faire b4
maintenant elle va pousser les deux cas
va jouer des gars tu pas pour les quatre
noms mais peut-être une raison donc 7
peut-être quatre où ces trois des quatre
plus tard nouvelle fois j'aime bien les
blancs
tu vas réussir à pousser des 4 es tu vas
avoir un petit avantage à mon avis ou
même peut-être sous ces trois pour jouer
avec f4 mais je pense jouer avec des
quatre ça fait quand même sens quoique
tu donnes la case de 5 du coup ce pion à
4 qui est bien placé mais qui a un jour
peut être faible
h3 et non nécessaire d'être très bien sa
mère d'être très bien elle peut prendre
du fou m l'orangé 2 pour bouger le fou
vers h 4g 5 pouces et f4 elle m'a quand
même l'air de bien mieux joué aux échecs
pour le moment à rick al maler de
dominer
on sera poisson bull ok c'est si c'est
bien joué c'est vrai que ça j'avais pas
forcément pensé et c'est assez bien joué
puisque c'est vrai que sur pions prend
cavaliers prend l'idée serait de revenir
vers des cats avec le cavalier donc à
fait roi age 2 est sûr qu on prend lyon
prend f5 peut être un mur a peut-être du
d4 à ce moment-là avoir dame b6 très
bien joué à l'empêchent des quatre et
sur g4 des blancs pour empêcher f5 y
aura cavalli j'ai six cavaliers f4 et en
plus elle menace fou prend f2 et
peut-être maintenant f5 voire même
cavalier f5 pour cavaliers des 4 c'est
ce qu'a le jour
vérification des 4 c'était son idée
prise est fou prend mal et noir ont bien
joué dans cette partie en réalité j'ai
pas trop compris ce qui se passait au
qui est les rois g2 je convaincs trouve
quoi la paf et damages 5 direct puisque
sur foot pro f de yahvé damev 5h 4h de
ma semblait un peu une perte d'un parent
une perte de temps parce que ça peut
être utile mais c'était pas c'était pas
forcément pressé pressé jouer roigé deux
mamans pions h4 c'est vrai qu'elle veut
peut-être h5 est d'alger qatar f5 s est
tendu comme position
elle veut pas d'un match 59e l'option h5
et la dame en f5 jugé trouvés croisé
deux étaient peut-être un coup inutile
par rapport à ce plan
focal calcul tour c'est 7 h 5 pour ces
huit dames g4 tour ces deux dards f5 et
c'est les blancs qui frappent les
premiers mais est-ce que ça fait si mal
on va voir on va voir ça que les noires
n'ayant pas joué f5 ils ont pas mis tout
plomb sur blanc c'est cette dame g4
peut-être
saddam ses huit fois fut cinq dames
c'est cette fougue 4 et peut-être safer
perpétuelle quoique fous quatre dames f6
peut-être peut-être d'un rêve si si si
pam g5 et le truc c'est que le fou des
quatre mains cas plus d'attaqués sur le
roi il est un peu plus fort que le
fougueux 4 mai b3 bien joué elle se lève
pas fixé le pion en b2 elle s'en
débarrassent tout de suite
elle va jouer tour bien au prochain tour
b1 j'imagine tours à huit reprises 17
prises 17 prises baisse est prise à 3
ok ça ça peut être semi dangereux pour
les blancs puisque si une tour arrivant
à deux via le pur f2 qui peut être
faible
la tension va du couloir aussi pour les
noirs parce que la cades h7 est contrôlé
donc en fait sur tourbe et un tour à 8
tours 17 frisbey cette prise baisse est
prise à 3 ignorer tourbe et 8 maths à la
fin donc sur tourbe et elle va
simplement jouer b6 et protéger son pion
et sacrifice de qualité en tout reprend
b6 way honnêtement j aurais pensé mais
je n'aurais pas joué parce que la simple
et bonne raison que j'ai l'impression
que je vais perdre le pion à en fait
avec les blancs jean roy et fuit 3e set
et la tour qui vient gratter le pion à
ça me paraît quasi imparable mal fait
tour à cette direct sur roy ici valoir
pions f6 marois et fit un petit coup à
tour à huile sur tourbe et six tours
assiste peut-être même à tour à 6 là
c'est juste une perte de temps à ce que
vient de faire les blancs ce qu'il faut
absolument garder une tour sur
l'échiquier mort fait tomber trois tours
b 6 tours bessette c'est juste perdre de
temps les
ils vont s'emparer du pion dans une
chasse à tour qu'est ce qu'elle fait ok
tu vas faire nul là quand même
au pire si tu as vraiment peur de tours
d'essai tu fais tour des huit maintenant
il ya un truc que je rate ou quoi
peut-être peur de pas pouvoir rpt
chasser la tour de desserte après alors
j'ai pas trop compris à quoi les tours b
7e rang à 3 3 et 4 tours à 7o 1 cytori
six tours ici f6 3,5 ok elle veut
rentrer jusqu'en f6 à ok je suis juste
tour des huit là
on apprend et qui franchement j'ai pas
trop compris la nulle avait peur de
laisser rentrer le roi et de se faire
maintenant elle a peut-être raison après
perso moi j'aurais eu droit aux sept
plus vite mais peut-être à la lui raison
peut-être eu raison de charges suivant
tu gagnes avec les noirs mais je pense
pas que tu sois gagnant mais tu joues tu
joues mais c'était au début de l'affairé
n'en est pas y avoir de moyens de suisse
a donné envie de jouer quoi mais non
mais non c'est vrai après m6 usa et si
c'est le droit qui rentrent en f 5 g 6
après ça tapait le pion g7 c'était
pénible et avait du mal à retourner que
la tour derrière rennes au mans ça
devait être ça devait être surtout il
aime ça surtout il aime ça c'est parce
que le plus besoin pour ça devait être
nulle elle ne l'est pas et doit déjà pas
dû penser dualité peut-être pas mieux en
réalité ouais vous avez vous avez
peut-être raison juste un peu frustrant
mais elle était peut-être pas mieux
trois parties trois nuls pour le moment
là on a une position qui est pas
à une vraie française mais qui re
transposant des positions de type
française perso j'aimerais beaucoup
jouer ça avec les blancs maintenant si
elle réussit à transférer sa dame / g4
ce serait fantastique pour les blancs ce
pas si facile parce qu'il ya un peu de
trafic patients il ya deux idées soit tu
fais d'amd de fou g3 d'un f4 dame j'ai
quatre mois je pour partir et pour ça
comme plans pour attaquer le pion et
peut-être avoir des fourrages 4 dans
certains cas de figure puisque bouger
des deux cavaliers ça parait dur à cause
du pion des cats qui peut rester en
prise donc moi j'ai serré de de faire ce
plan je commencerai peut-être par petit
rock pour éviter les mauvaises surprises
ou paroisse f1 peut-être réfère tout ok
t'as tour à trois tons g3 aussi encore
plus fort peut-être mais sûrement encore
plus fort tour à tour à tour g3 ray et
dont j'ai trois maintenant quel âge
aurait repris du cavalier
non je repris du cavalier peu perso je
serai replacer les pièces sur cavaliers
prend juin reprise cavalli est fait
j'aurais ramené la dame verger 4
j'en ai gagné des positions comme ça ok
alors maintenant avec les blancs tu peut
déjà penser à bouffer une foire met un
cavalier en d4 l'est d'alger quatre pour
fou g6 ça peut être un plan mal fait
froid et faim tu l'avais vue sur la
chaîne j'avais fait une partie steijns
ou car torte un peu avec ses esprit de
sacrifice parce que tu peux voir
sacrifié avec les blancs de partout et
les noirs qui ont vraiment pas de juin
et noir qui sont complètement fermés et
qui n'ont pas trop d'idées
c'est avec la tour enregistrons peu plus
poussé j'ai quatre ans ça c'est bien ce
qu'a fait arica elle ramène le quart
ayant ses seins qu'elle veut le mettre
peut-être vers 4 1 jour pas forcément
tout de suite mais il vise sept cases en
tout cas bambi 6 ok elle veut jouer pour
b400 que les plants étaient un poil mou
quand même un poil timide même si je
continue à aimer les blancs j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu timide
j'aime bien là encore dame 17 vient
contre la case 4 pour matt
éventuellement un cavalier et finalement
il se décide à prendre ans et six à
faire cavalier des cats qu'elle aurait
pu faire depuis longtemps
et peut-être elle va aller pour pour la
dame angers 4 et toi tu peux faire un
truc genre dame j'ai quatre tours f3
attaquer là dessus et c'est sacrifier
quelque part un jour peut-être tu fous
g6 sacrifiera ou peut-être du tours fc
est quelque chose
voilà ça qui est le plus en prise j'ai
oublié mais faut vraiment ramener la
dame angers 4 et bouger cette tour est
préparé mais on savait qu'il a dû
cavaler bon cavalier 4 c'est peut-être
rien c'est de l'oim
des quatre alors vraiment péché cavalli
ou 4 à tout prix est peut-être dû dame
g41 peut être intéressant on va voir
comment elle décide d'évoluer position
position blanche qui est qui est
toujours correct mais c'est vrai qu'à la
est là elle n'a pas vraiment évolué
depuis 10-15 coup et ça peut être un peu
inquiétant pour les blancs il faut un
jour ou l'autre
réussir à mettre la pression qui pour le
moment c'est parce qu'elle réalise ffu
b15 genre qu'elle exploite pas du tout
les idées de potes de potentiel
sacrifices avec les blancs ce qui est
problématique et elle perd beaucoup de
temps après on sait qu'elle joue bien
quand elle a peu de temps à la pendule
donc kavanagh 4 le retour
alors là je commence à me dire que
c'était très noir qui vont finir par
contre et 1
la force de rien faire on sent qu'elle
trouve pas de plan en fait peut-être
ajout peu de françaises et elle connaît
pas trop les idées auxquelles fait ces
quatre ans et c'est un bon coup pierre
louis qui demandent si aux échecs à haut
niveau il ya beaucoup de femmes n'y a
pas du tout femme en fait un haut niveau
des gens pour ça qu'il est on a féminin
pour qu'il puisse y avoir des femmes
enfin à haut niveau fin dans dans la
catégorie féminine dans ce cas très bien
joué
zéro tu as un top 100 mondial ah ouais
ouais on a zéro dans top 100 mondial moi
j'appellerai le top le vraiment le haut
niveau le top 20 mondial un perso moi le
haut niveau ça c'est vraiment dans l'est
dans les sports comme ça c'est dans les
dents les dans les disciplines comme le
top 20 mondial où tu as vraiment une
chance entre guillemets de viser un
titre mondial
faut quand même être déjà bien classé et
donc et donc ouais dans le top 20
mondial dans à zéro donc finalement
réussi à prendre le g7 a lâché j'aime
bien j'aime bien les blancs nouveau mais
bon j'imagine un petit d'am dam f3
menace la tour f 8 va être sûrement joué
et peut-être tout reprend f7 est fou g6
finalement qui paraît fort après faudra
pas se faire contrer avec cavaliers
prend b2 ou jusqu'à l'escale menacerait
en quelque chose avec les blancs enfin
quand je dis quelque chose c'est plus
que ça auquel va cette dame prend à vii
et cavalli prend aussi sans réalité
genre cavaliers prend b2 d'emprunt fc
trois des huit qui est prend 1,6 donc si
elle menace ça il faut parer la menace
vous prend des quatre n'a vraiment pas
très envie on n'a peut-être pas le choix
voilà on peut faire trois des huit
laisser prendre f7 et jouer roi c'est
cette âme héros assez ça tient encore
cavaliers pros e6 et surtout prend des
quatre peut-être tout reprend des quatre
un problème maintenant menaçant ici
vraiment diagne elian danielian qui va
peut-être conclure allez allez vraiment
forte dans ces speech s elle est
vraiment vraiment vraiment un adversaire
redoutable pour avoir quand même gagné
les qualifications et la tour des six
est le problème c'est que le fouillis
bloc le pion sait si elle pousse y prend
et si elle prend elle prendra ses 6 et
alcoy râle pions plus tard ce fou g6 qui
est très bien placé d'amd 5d 3d cette
fois ci ce peut-être en p3 solide
ces deux prises ces deux prises ces deux
prises à quatre reprises comme ça ça
reprend la dame et il ya foule et 5 qui
arrive au prochain ça semble cuit pour
la jeune indienne
là c'est fini
[Musique]
jamais fita me sens bien jouer il faut
prendre peut-être ici à may a pu on
prend et sur roy ses huit dames f8
hockey l'a pas vu elle a peut-être vu
autre chose
je pense que ça gagner un pion prend
auquel va jouer la finale de pions qui
est gagnante aussi parce que j'ai cinq
si on prend et agissent ici c est le roi
est pas dans le carré et donc sa gamme
pour les blancs ouais danielian qui a
bien joué un qui étaient précises et qui
prend l'avantagé mais là vraiment parce
que gagner les qualifs c'est dur bas de
macquenoise tête de série numéro 1 c'est
dur et là elle refait un gros début de
match et je la mettrais favorite du
match personnellement elle est en
contrôle elle fait pas d'erreur elle est
là elle est vraiment forte avait
peut-être favorite de ce speech s ces
arméniens qui sont qui sont de
redoutables beats à 1
on les a vus on les a vus en pro de
chasse ligue on les a vu aussi dans les
speechs à ces années précédentes y est
trop jeune qui s'était qualifié avant de
perdre et c'est vraiment vraiment des
bons joueurs du blitz 1 ils ont ils ont
la réputation d'être de bons joueurs de
blitz t il sont ils sont vraiment ils
sont vraiment sur lie à papillons prend
1,4
ok rock si ça va le pion le pur est
clouée sur je pensais à petit on prend
des trois de base mais avoue prend
bessette
puis on prend deux prises de on pourra
prendre à 8 on pourra y avoir ces six
ans ferme et truquées jouer pour la
qualité de moins mais
donc sa maman escure avec les noirs on
vous avec eux cinq pour jouer qui sait
si ces cas et des cas peut-être mais
aurait peut-être dû fouet 3 je crois
fouet 3 s'est contracté ces six direct
ouais ça c'est logique d'être h3 pour
les blancs pour réussir à préparer fouet
3 lf où sera bien placé 3 s'il y arrive
mais sur camaïeu cinq têtes des 3 5 avec
cinq minutes on a vraiment le temps de
jouer un c'est une cadence qui est assez
longue
h3 scaroni un effort en beat frey après
peut-être un peu moins maintenant parce
qu'il a un peu un peu vieilli si je puis
me permettre mais mais il a il a été un
excellent joueur de blitz salut à la
yann 26 tombes et 8 donc trouver une
idée c'est de simplement protéger le fou
et 7,3 jeu créé par peut-être f 4 5 pour
faire une belle prise d' espaces
allaient droit
alors que vont faire les noirs peut
quand même gardé cette idée de mettre un
pion de 5,1 fait 1,8 cette f4 jorda
match 5 il faudra voir quoi faire mais
cavani j 4 échecs ça mène pas bien loin
en frais juste à point que la machin que
sera ce week-end caïd gk3 j'ai un fou
ces cinq donc damage 5 sacré comme une
menace qu'on peut pas à prendre à la
légère
menaces kg 4 évoquée jusqu'à 3h un à
l'arrière est fou c'est 5 quand même
temps c'est un peu je suis en peut-être
qu'elle fait des six pour le moment à
trois noms qu'elle voit elle veut que le
plus près une des ses bien joué ça à 3
parce que sa force se font à prendre une
décision mais comme salade à main elle
couvre la case h5
c'est bien joué mais maintenant les
noirs qui joue au 5 rue des genêts faire
f5 g4 g5 1 pour les blancs là pour jouer
un peu comme dans les indiennes ne fait
qu'aider cinq doivent être bon aussi
basse alsace qui prend ses sept
donc c'est très bien joué par pas pour
le truc d' attaques brutales la joue ce
petit coup de carhaix les dessins qui
est bien pensé peut-être maintenant les
récipients prend 1,5 et pro f 6 à
regarder qui forcerait g prendre que sur
pions pro qui est des cinq intermédiaire
il ya d'amd 5 contre intermédiaire
mais bon est ce que c'est si bien je
l'intrus comme ça pas sûr un leroy il
est dur à toucher quand même pas sur elf
f5 maintenant elle veut jouer avec g4 g5
simple efficace et donc foule 3
on prend le prends le truc prises puis
on prend moi je prendrais plutôt 2 à 2
tu peux pas parce qu'avec cinq ans prise
donc tu peux peut-être prendre des 4
elle prend 2 c ces 5 va être un coup ici
pour les noirs qui a et b 5 ça paraît un
peu bizarre il ya 4 et les c'est fou
prend des 4 comprend des quatre dames
prend des quatre n'a pas forcément envie
[Musique]
encore que pour répondre au chat dans ma
femme ne joue pas du tout aux échecs
quasiment et c'est tant mieux
dk sa prise je pas par ces cinq quoi
faire après tu vas prendre la marée mais
ok tu prends de la tour et fils le pion
études active
ça suffit tout reprend encore il faut
prend que j'en prends dame prend
peut-être fait tour ces deux et wade
fait pas grand-chose fait illusion
elle fait cavaler prendre sur d'armes
preuve autour des 8 ouais ok pourquoi
pas possible aussi je pense que les
plans ou quand même prendre l'option des
six as et tour des huit dames ses sept
tours 17
assez vicieux donc dames 6 échecs forces
éprises prise
c'est très bien jouer une nouvelle fois
en défense
donc peut-être six tours f7 est jouable
avec l'idée d'utiliser l'avant-poste sur
la septième et a très envie de faire
flouer fin fut c4 parce que tu es fou en
f1 tout reprend aussi ce tour f2 et
après c'est de mettre le fou en c4 et
remettre cette tour en f1 pour ses sets
ça va avoir la même idée mais encore
mieux
elle avoue enfin je pense
un tour c1
elle va vouloir passer le fourrage 3 n
en sais bien joué
faut pas oublier que tour fff est
maintenant complètement si tu es salaam
un peu mélangé tout c'était pas si bien
joué que ça
donc elle peut faire fous ces quatre
peut-être et tour f1 pour essayer
d'aller faire du tour f 7 et les noirs
sont un peu organisés à la perdu un ou
deux temps
ouais c'est difficile que et lina qui
défend bien donc à fait tout reprend à 7
qui est assez intelligent prend 4 c'est
ça mais c'est vrai que après 3h friture
a jamais de maths même cavalier aussi
s'en fout c'est 4 jouer way et foutez 5
maintenant peut-être on peut être fou
des 5
j'ai l'impression que ça va ça va
défendre côté noir même s'il reste en
difficulté
elle va tenir
sûrement faire tour ses huit dix
machines pour essayer de s'activer avec
du tour ces deux échecs
ouais c'est fait un tour prend b6 tour
ces deux tours b tour tour des trois
martyrs ont tenté quelque chose comme ça
les rois sur internet pas mal wii fit
jouer tempo bref cette affaire roi g8 le
retour la tour accepte les moins bien
placés dans le sens où elle elle est là
interdit quelque part les tours
combessie ce parce qu'elle reste en
prise toi demain autour des 3 peut-être
et latour noires s'activent ou key des
cat way prise prise du pion tour f 7
tours g6 pas le fait des 3 à 1 c'est
hyper mal hein pas le défend vraiment
très très bien
elle défend vraiment très très bien
ouais grosse défense de deux danielian
une nouvelle fois un qui montre sa force
en défense les blancs qui vont devoir
prendre le père pète elle perd jamais
elle défend vraiment très très très très
bien et fait clairement tour ces deux
ténors sauver non mais il faudrait la
voir j'aimerais bien avoir à la fête
face à des très bons joueurs parce
qu'elle défend
j'ai l'impression qu'elle défend de
manière très précise c'est vraiment un
gros point fort avec quelques secondes
sur l'échiquier seulement faire tout re
2 elle va peut-être carrément la gagne
est allé tour c'est un peut-être pour
menacer maths en un ça ne fait pas bien
loin des affiches trois des huit ici
elle fait tour ces deux grands prix
saemann entoure ces sept
ok bon j'ai l'impression qu'elle a raté
les enfants c'est peut-être les blancs
qui joue la gagne de nous voiler tour
ces trois dames prise comme ça c'est mal
joué je pense maintenant 3 5g 4 ça c'est
élémentaire sagan pour les blancs
incroyable retournement de situation la
g5 h5 g6 c'est ça c'est élémentaire
double retournement de situation dans
cette partie
page 7 et arica qui l'emportent et qui
égalise
surprenant surprenant parce que sur
tours c'est un roi des 8
on avait l'impression qu'ils allaient
avoir des deux tours e daniel 11 kg en
action quand elle est mieux je joue
moins bien quant à elle en a les moyens
sont que c'est une heure cette
forteresse défend très bien fait plus de
fautes
mais quand elle est mieux elle a plus de
mal à mener le jeu
c'est un style 1
c'est un style doit sentir plus à l'aise
dans les positions où elle doit défendre
donc ce petit gambie dame décliné trois
affaires foot et 3 probablement sept
fous des six pascal affaire d'âme c'est
du rock ou tour c'est un même qu'elle
rock les noirs qui vont faire un six
intermédiaire fouache 4 rock et
maintenant tourbe et un don qu'elle
prépare la fameuse attaque deux
minorités avec b 4 des 5 est sur b4 faut
toujours se méfier du coup b5 voir qu'on
a bien entendu eu quatre ce que s'il est
noir réussissent à mettre le cavalier en
c4 ça peut être carrément pénible
bon alors
comment est ce que les blancs vont
continuer peut-être des quatre à quatre
quand même pour le moment on a vu sur b5
on allait faire re 4 et contre attaquer
au centre
ok elle a fait tout un tour 8 prépare un
peu 4 aussi juste un peu bizarre
peut-être de jouer avec eux quatre ces
ajouts tourner en rond c'est pas très
grave
elle prépare part à trois pour le moment
bon ben c'est cette logique elle va
peut-être faire fou j'ai 4 et cava lieu
quatre tours c'est un donc là on voit
que les blancs n'ont pas forcément fait
une belle série de coupes si on fait
tourbe et impôts pour préparer b 4 à 3
pour préparer des cas depuis tour c'est
un ca sent que c'est pas c'est pas fou
fou là attention ne pas faire cavaliers
4 qui serait thématiques à cause que le
cas il prend des cinqs été cloué et
maintenant finalement b 4 pour les
blancs il y arrive mais il menace même
pas encore quoi que ce soit parce qu'à 4
n'est même pas une menace sur les dames
prend b4 donc la tourette ans est un cas
ont largement le temps de jouer un coup
comme cavalier e 4 ici à mon avis vous
fêtiez betis qui est très bien aussi
elle vise la case la case c44 cliquez
ici 5
les agapes prise à quatre reprises f3
des caïds et 7
je peux je suis étonné que les paquets
qui soit bien plus vite en quatre mais
bon
j'ai pas forcément trop aimer ces
échanges après c'est pas forcément ma
spécialité non plus ces structures là
mais j'ai l'impression que les blancs
pouvoir faire du fkng kg 5
bref cas 3g 2g quatre tours h un g5
genre sont maintenant les blancs des
plans clairs et j'ai pas été très
convaincu par par le jeu des noirs là
sur les derniers coups après je sais pas
comment il aurait fallu jouer ou même si
c'est mauvais mais juste à m'a pas paru
elle veut mettre le cavalier en c4 mais
ces cavaliers en c4 il va pas faire
grand chose
ce fait qu'ils aient baissé ce qui c'est
quatre palmarès j'ai dépensé deux coups
encore de faire tout rage cinq tours ici
et en fait on va déjà préparé g5 et
palmarès ouais faut peut-être faire
quand même et je sais pas c'est un pas
l'air peux même te faire g5 direct je
sais pas mais qui est disons fou prend
ces quatre là et tout rachat
j'ai cinq direct c'est un autre coup
auquel je t'entends de penser qu'elle
imagine ce que tu peux laisser ça en
prise parce que tu peux tu as deux
écoles soit tu prends vous prend pions
prend damage 7,3 et fuit d'un match
depuis trois ans cette dame prend g7
fait quand même un peu peur ce fait
cavalier à trois dames quelque part soit
tu es tours 6 toi aussi j'aurais eu
super peur de fouet cinq personnes
avaient faux seins qu'elle voulait
peut-être tout reprend 2,3 qu'elle est
maintenant
3 y'a pas à cause de france et quatre
mais six ont fait faux f5 leurs atouts
reprend 1,3 puis on prend h 6 pions
prend tout reprend h6 aurait quand même
eu un bon feeling pour les blancs perso
mais pas sûr que c'était si mon café
dame sert elle empêche elle prépare faux
f5
après parfois f5
alors trêve cinq semaines pas une
qualité ici à ses heures qui arrive est
carrément rien vu en fait où elle avait
vu à la fée g6 par ah bon c'est moi qui
avais rien vu et oui maintenant qu'il ya
plus adamence et de il ya plus les
trucages ci s'est tous bien joué mais là
c'est un nouveau bordel là c'est un
nouveau bordel aux prises prises en cas
d' imagine
les grecs c'est quand même une
difficulté en difficulté mais qui défend
bien
maintenant est-ce qu'elle va prendre des
cadors sont qu'il faut faire parce que
sinon tu vas perdre g5 pour rien et la
colmater avec la dame madame g8
probablement pour passer avec tourage
suite hémisphère dam des huit matches et
c'est cette position que je pensais je
me dit il faudra trouver un bon coup
pour les noirs ici puisque la menace
blanche est forte
est ce qu'il ya un bon coup même est ce
que bon coup il y à ici pour les noirs
ça semble compliqué on veut tous raffûte
umeå sera dame ait fuité dan des huit la
tour à schwyz apparaît très fort qu'elle
tente et cavaliers prend d'amd 8 mai roi
bouge au pire d'un refrain f 63.9 d'un
procès sept ayant pas et peut-être
cavalli non mais qu en est il ya sa tour
qui sera en prise donc tour ici
cavaliers la dame échec crois là donc on
va voir qui avait promis 5 et force est
de toute façon
sinon il ya damas fuite matt d'amd hui 3
600 f 53.5 sera obligatoire parce que
sur thur f5 dame f5 adam prend ses 7 et
ça va couvrir donc comprendre wap
renforcée pour h 5 échecs 3g 6 forcé et
tourage six échecs et c'est fini là ça
gagne si on prend roi prend ça gagne
peut-être ça ça gagne aussi
oui ok to recettes et puis on prend avec
cinq échecs et on va gagner aussi plus
simple donc carey lieu cette seul coup
une dame français 7
il va y avoir un ou deux échecs mais pas
plus
et ça va être gagner immédiatement donc
ça va redonner un point d'avancé à la
joueuse arménienne qui reprend
l'avantagé et qui remet end un point
après six parties donc si partis une
heure de jeu déjà et un point en avance
pour la joueuse arménienne qui joue bien
qui dominent le match pour le moment qui
réussit à jouer vite dans l'est quant à
la peu de temps et qui après tout ne
semble me semble armé pour pour se
qualifier après je m'inquiète pas avec
pour le temps parce que dans le match
précédent elles avaient déjà eu des
difficultés avec la pendule mais elle
avait réussi à bien à bien se mettre à
niveau
quand il a quand il a fallu quand s'est
tenue trois plus un élu en plus elle a
réussi à bien ce à bien se ressaisir et
à jouer plus vite dès le début des
parties
alors nouvelle petite anglaise position
qui paraît correct pour les blancs
s'étaient alors on prend des cinq dames
détroit lloris et 6 pour le moins
égalité matérielle entre les deux
joueuses 1 puis emprunte dam des trois
est meilleure et puis on sait si donc
fou b2 elle fait le double enquête
hausse avec la position est très ouverte
à la famille pion au centre donc les
deux fous b2 et j'ai deux sont très bien
placés et font un boulot d'enfer sur les
grandes diagonales le fou qui attaquent
jusqu'en g7 est celui-là qui attaque de
l'autre côté donc c'est vraiment deux
excellentes pièce est maintenant
cavalier e 5 donc le cavalier qui vient
s'approcher ok pour le moment sa menace
rien mais peut-être on veut même dieu 4d
4 1 jour ok sable ocre et les fous donc
ça serait la mauvaise nouvelle mais d'un
autre côté ça permettrait
prendre de l'espace au centre les blancs
qui va aussi jouer pour f4 là je trouve
que les blancs ont pris tout cas une
position plus agréable à jouer
ils vont pouvoir jouer avec 4 à tout
moment alors comment est ce que les
noirs vont réagir
on va voir
c'est jamais évident à disposition ou
tuer l'adversaire qui a les pions sans
trop parce que tu peux pas difficile de
faire des ruptures
ces pollutions qui pour moi sont
vraiment compliqué à jouer avec les
noirs tout cas que je trouve vraiment
très complexe à jouer bien voir comment
quand elle évolue
elle prend son temps en tout cas faut 6
bon ça pour commencer c'est logique et
maintenant des quatre donc les langues
qu'ils peuvent vouloir jouer pour quatre
des cinq qui peut voir que pour 4 f 4 à
5 go qu'elle joue sur la l1 c'est là
qu'elle a sa majorité pions c'est tout à
fait logique qu'ayant fonds e cat f4 et
s'affaiblisse un petit peu mais prennent
masse des espaces au centre c'est ce que
la joueuse indienne a décidé de faire
don que quatre pour aller jouer f4
avancer ses pions et continuer à prendre
de l'espace
il ya ici c'est peut-être f4 maintenant
j'ai joué par la suite bien évidemment
f5 chasser le fou et une fois que le fou
sera chassé on pourra imaginer du dam b3
qui attaquera bessette et à vii
elle commence par à 4 elle veut
probablement empêché 1,4 pour réussir au
moment opportun a gagné la case d3 et a
créé une double attaque qui doutait donc
elle veut chasser le cavalier la d5 est
une option peut être pas normalement les
blancs un avantage des espaces donc ils
veulent garder les pièces 1 tout comme
cavale heat detroit pas réparé candidats
ici pour garder les cavaliers maintenir
la poussée toute façon les pions
centraux sont bien défendus après on
peut aussi aller pour la prise c'est
aussi faisable
elle joue des cinq des cinq aussi
possible bien entendu cavaliers prendre
la sueur pions prend est amené à mon
avis tout reprend 2,6 et surtout
prochain qui a peut-être fou prend des
5s que des 5 t vraiment un bon coup je
suis pas sûr je vous prends des cinq
francs j'ai cette frange et 7 est donc
là elle prend comme ça elle va prendre
ces six mais là ça assez changeant d un
ça va échanger en c6 et ça va aller vers
la nulle tranquillement hockey américain
qui a raté une nouvelle occasion en
faisant une erreur je pense qu'elle
avait un petit avantage quand même avec
ses pions centraux elle semble être
quand même pas mal avancé peut-être que
au lieu de la 4f quatre étaient
meilleurs après j'ai pas la science
infuse non plus mais peut-être étaient 5
ou plus précis alors on a peut-être une
indienne peut-être une pire que plus tôt
[Musique]
elle met pas le pion cecafa ne rentre
pas dans l'east indienne avec les blancs
mais là on imagine le 4 kir transpose
dans une pire cas parce que je les vende
classique avec fougue 2 h 3 fou 3 à rock
ska va décider pour autre chose
fu détroit aussi possible top et ashes
humaine que les plans changent dans ce
cas là oui entre la pire qu'ils allaient
stars viennent c'est juste deux
ouvertures complètement différente de ph
donc les plans sont complètement
différents effectivement la hiérarchie
ont essayé de rejouer pour 5 pour
égaliser le sens tu peux aussi jouer
parfois éprouvé 5 des quatre pour s'en
prendre au centre deux côtés mais elle
joue pour eux cinq donc plan très
classique + alami la dame ans et 7
j'ai envie de dire tout cela est très
logique à 4 qui vient prendre de
l'espace elle empêche des cinq et on se
développera peut-être un peu plus tard
sur la colonne départs dam des deux
tours f d un peut-être parfois on mettra
même le fou on verra avec le foire plus
maintenant peut-être question
ce fut le cas doit être protégé on peut
aussi et c'est jouer avec toi peut-être
poussé quatre plus tard pour s'en
prendre un peu option à vii
tour 1 il vient se mettre sur la colonne
eu en face à face à face à la colonne
face à la tour noire qui elle aussi sur
la colonne eu bien évidemment pour ne
pas se laisser attaquer le pion de 4
donc et 17 et il s était fait peut être
pousser 4 x 2 pour se mettre là dessus
cette diagonale meinau remettront le x e
6 mai du couté changerait ton mauvais
fou ça peut être une option
mettre le foie en ces cas peut être une
option fait dam des deux fois six en
revanche on l'avait un peu vu de la part
de marie ce bague c'est généralement pas
trop le bon plan parce que c'est le
mauvais food et noir alors après si on
peut mener une attaque rapide assure le
roi
ça peut être bon mais dans cette
position là je suis loin d'être sûr
alors si on prend là tout est possible
ah ouais que le pion c'est qu'ils aient
pensé 4 ça change tout et bien sûr
balade est apte à pousser 4 par exemple
est faussée car j'aime bien parce qu'il
ya plus cavalier b6 et maintenant kg 5
une option mais un cavalier au cices
encore tour d un cavalier pranger 5 est
fou au 6 mai bon les blancs pouvoir
presser et est rentré une d'amendés 6
d'avoir loiseau s'il ya une supposition
bâle iii tout à fait d'accord on année
s'ils savaient pas le temps il manque un
tempo dames deux protège le fou est
peut-être un coup à mach 6 maintenant
pour se libérer le fou et mettre le fou
en c5 ça une certaine logique
les deux joueuses qui jouent pas malin
cette position
jamais les âges cinq cas et qui va venir
en f4 maintenant arica qui joue bien en
live on l'avait déjà vu face à marie ce
vague elle joue vraiment pas mal c'est
ses positions après les blancs
continuent un peu apprécié la menace
peut-être du cavalier p5 dame eu cette
logique elle sort du clouage tour d2
hockey avec les blancs elle a peut-être
le temps de doubler mais il lui manque
un coup pour vraiment mettre la pression
depuis tout à l'heure à rica qui a
réussi autant prêt à défendre et la tête
le temps de faire tour des six et des
changements encore plus mais elle part
pour cavaliers f4 donc sur fou prend
pions prends tu fais des pions double
est né le foot cazenave à s'ouvrir il
sera fort et si tu prends pas peut-être
que les noirs veulent faire d'alger 5
pour aller menacer m'attendais quand
même la mefa elle va colmater et
maintenant peut-être comme dame b 4
était possible mais peut-être ça
laissait tour des 8 mai tour des
sixièmes mieux ça échange les tours et
puis on viendra avec la dame peut-être
plus tard en b 4 pour taper un peu les
pions blancs cas là je pense si les
blancs font rien le prochain ces dames
p4 donc le quai qui revient aussi
souvent des devises la casse des 4es
aveu d'amd 4 donc probablement dame c4
ici pour les blancs pour revenir un peu
colmater cette aile dames et noir qu une
position très correct
rien qui est très très solide en défense
cette fois fuite ici un coup candidats
car il y des quatre aussi là ya pas mal
d'options pour les noirs mais les blancs
qui sont qu'une position des santons ils
ont de bons fous quand même la fée caïds
et quatre dans quelle menace un peu
qu'elle prend ses deux enfants elle
menace aux tca et prend ses 2 alors
comment ça continue côté blanc prises
des catcheurs ont reprise de la dame
j'aurais imaginé mais reprises à
reprises à dania vais dame français si
ce pardon donc reprise du pion qui
avaient lieu deux peut-être c'est ce que
ici on a envie de jouer d'être ok faut
faire gaffe parce que si les bleus ont
réussi à faire f k 3g de roy f-35 genre
de truc g4 et prendre de l'espace de
partout ça peut être dangereux parce que
le cavalier va être plus fort que le fou
et si on fait ces cinq on va donner des
cavaliers f4 qui est des cinq cafés
d'amd c'est 3g 2 va jouer pour déjà je
crois j'imagine c'est chose faite
attention cavaliers f4 manants qui est
des trois lacs et qui va sûrement
revenir en d3 bombay 3 pour commencer
elle maintient la pression ici c'est pas
idiot et kiev 4 qui est des trois pour
jouer après 4,5 peut-être au f4 f5 ce
que fout et 5 et un coup faut 5 sera
sûrement un f4 d'être faut jouer f5
alors mais on n'aime jamais trop toucher
à ses pions pas facile pour arica qui
restent avec leur apport matériel
désagréable dame cavaliers plus fort que
dame fou et ce pion des cats qui est
bloqué sur la couleur de son fouet qui
peut qui peut plus bouger
5 me un peu provoqué quelque chose
proposant le château d'amou 6 mai 2006
déjà cette finale à elle elle fait un
peu peur quand même aime beaucoup de
pions sur noir et une idée simple pour
les blancs faire cavalier des huit
provoqué ces cinq est allée est allé
avec leroy fer l'autoroute allait raser
les pions il faut 5 et c'est un fou g7
qui est des trois probablement c5
telle est ce qu'un coup comme d'amd 5
intéressant c'est la dame prend prise f5
qui va empêcher au droit de venir
rejoindre qu'elle revient en f4 et à mon
avis elle veut dam des cinq ici parce
que prise et cavaliers prend la finale
où elle est excellente le roi va aller
ok là je pense d'amd 5 et fort pas le
temps de faire [ __ ] en f4 et sur dame
cette cave a lieu trois ans n'aura
progrès si on aura réussi à mener la
dame en d5
j'imagine que cette finale doit être
intéressante tout cas perso je suis allé
pour dan des 5,6 s'est pas fait
un peu étonné final me paraissait bonne
c'est ce que je me trompe pas jouer avec
à 5
c'est peut-être là le maître le pion à
six est allé jouer la finale après ok
c'est peut-être pas bête le pion à 6 va
être très bien placé ça permettra un
jour avoir des dames des cinq prises
prises et jouer pour b4 et avait joué
pour les pions passé là bas ce genre de
choses
le cac est de moins en moins bien la
pendule qui fait dame 17 donc à l'attack
le pion f3 qui le défend fiction qui est
dur dan 17 ans le cavalier f4 dam des
cinq qui va arriver ou à 6 intermédiaire
tout cas danielian si elle gagne cette
partie ça lui ferait plus 2 elle
commencera à faire l'écart à l'option
prend ça ça m'a surpris à elle veut
mettre le quart ayant des cinq est
menacée le pion b6 je suis assez surpris
j'avais l'impression qu'avec le pion à 6
pour aller menacer les quais prend b 6 à
7 machin et dames
je faisais quand vous dites quand à 6 en
fait si vous rentrez dans des finales de
cavaliers contrefout vous menacerait des
cayes prend b 6 à 7 à 8 j'avais perdu
une partie en championnat du monde - de
16 contre thomas chef qui comme ça mais
bon c'est peut-être bien joué parce que
c'est vrai que ce pion b6 il va être
très affaibli est un peu comme dame b5
web des quatre duels vais changer les
pions elle se fait contre attaquer
maintenant
qu'elle a pris beaucoup des spasmes et
peut-être carrick a maintenant on peut
essayer d'aller avec du talent g4 faire
quelque chose dames g4 d'amd 1 allée de
la prison b4 ça me prend des 4 et
peut-être maintenant elle est passée
avec d'avray dame c6r position qui est
un peu peut-être p5 ici je peux à quoi
ça sert aya cavaliers apsys menaces
pardon donc dame c5 logique frisbey
quatre baies 5 maintenant wayne ont
jamais perdu une finale contre tomas
celle ci comme ça ils m'avaient vis avec
un choc et un v6 et j'ai pas vraiment de
mérite à aman rappeler parce que c'était
le meilleur lots de ma catégorie en
moins de 16 et j'avais une bonne
position que j'ai perdu donc ça m'a un
peu marqué il était déjà peut-être de
1600 à l'époque c'était un genre de cire
ou déjà comme aujourd'hui quoi en plus
joueur très technique très très fort et
quand j'ai revu à moscou se rappeler de
notre parti ça qui était marrant
ok donc là les blancs qui vont
progresser petit à petit poucet 5 ça
voilà que 8 points 8
[Musique]
ok les blancs qui ont pas réussi à la
gagner et je sais pas ce pion à 6 pour
l'âge le plus stratégique dam des 5 et 6
lemaitre l'adamant bessette et tout ça
ça me paraissait plus fort pour les
blancs après j'en sais rien c'est des
joueurs qui sont censés être plus fort
que moi donc je pense que je pense que
c'est moi qui me plante un peu mieux que
moi donc mieux voir ces choses là donc
on en reste à +1 et c'est probablement
la dernière partie en 5 + 1 puisqu'il
reste huit minutes 40 et les parties
sont quand même assez longue
donc on attendait beaucoup du on est con
et trois victoires c'est ça si je ne
m'abuse puisqu'on a eu une victoire de
arica et deux victoires de danielian
j'ai l'impression
si ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut et
donc un match avec quand même énormément
de nul puisqu'il ya eu huit partis donc
cinq nuls 3 victoires les arénas pas sur
wii dont un frère sur mon fils quand
même pas oui mais avez-vous à faire
semblant que si on va faire semblant
qu'elle joue bien pendue coup est ce
qu'on peut faire des 5,5 et c'est pas du
tout mon répertoire
kevin fuite rappelle la partie en
février 2006 quand ils avaient fait une
course régulière oui bien sûr bien sûr
j'ai fait nul tu as plus +8 sur l'ordi
j'ai fait mieux j'avais plus de temps et
j'ai craqué mais bon j'avais été j'étais
complètement perdant à la fin de
l'ouverture
j'avais voulu jouer à eux trois poisons
qui s'est transformée dans un genre de
grünfeld où je comprenais rien et après
après glen johnson qui avait refusé de
rentrer dans les complications en milieu
de jeu et j'avais réussi à m'échapper à
même de venir gagnant avant de
lamentablement faire nul comme à ses
plus tard mais bon je n'arrivais plus à
calculer beaucoup d'heures de jeu mais
j'avais plus à calculer une partie sympa
contre glen plein que je connais depuis
longtemps qu'un grand maître british qui
vient en france du mali depuis plus
d'une vingtaine d'années maintenant
mais qui est très sympa très flegmatique
j'adorerais vraiment très sympa comme
comme jeune homme on va dire ça lui fera
plaisir si jamais il écoute toujours à
deux et peut chasser la tour avec la
valise c3 au cas où mais qui a fait un
rêve confié que l'état puisse être
engagée a pu s'attendre mais il a tenté
des pièges
mais c'est une partie marrante ils
jouent bien ils jouent bien et glen à il
joue bien il s'accroche bien qu'ils
assurent qu'ils ont été chassés à tours
qui revient à trois saisons grâce à une
époque souhaite un bon prof un j'imagine
djene kaba engines c'est un bon prof de
l'aisne tout cas il est très sympa donc
j'imagine qu'ils la sympathique et c'est
une qualité importante pour être prof
donc dame f3 elle s'en prend aux pions
bessette qui essaient 5 20 ski et prend
des trois expositions un peu un peu
strange alors tu veux pas faire des
casques un clouage phocéen j'ai pensé
que j'avais peur des tours a un qui
pouvaient rodez je disais que si les
toits us à rentrer en 1 mais peut-être
c'est pas si grave
y a un truc comme ça il fait chaud donné
la calèche et prendre en d3 mais bon
c'est un peu too much j'aurais pas fait
sans match en blitz mais bon quoi que tu
prends des 3 es tu joues sur l'activité
de folie c'était pas si mal
elle fait cavalier prend des 3a oui et
surtout prend à 3 quels problèmes de
pardon pardon c'était une tactique assez
élémentaire je râle un peu de grain j'ai
raté ça et là danielian qui est vraiment
en train de prendre le dessus est là
parce qu'elle va prendre f2 tout cas je
crois qu'elle peut commencer par quatre
ça c'est ça mange pas de pain l affaire
qui a ébranlé f2 au prochain et tourne à
-2 quand même pour pour harry cas ce
serait un peu un peu dur je pense parce
qu'elle a un peu dominé le tout début de
match et puis après danielian petit à
petit qui a pris le dessus et ça va être
serré que ça peut être un poil
inquiétant pour pour la joueuse indienne
ça peut être un poil inquiétant pour la
joueuse indienne a que deux points dans
un match comme ça où il ya beaucoup de
nuls où les parties sont pas et à
peut-être tour à 2 1 qui est pénible ou
la torah de là ça semble s'assemblent
penny mais h3 juste ça ça fait peur de
se faire clouer comme ça doublement
parce que sur cavaliers prend il est
peut-être dame profit d'un premier
fissure est quand même mieux au québec
quatre noms elle tient elle tient encore
ça sert quand même on a dont on a deux
joueurs sont très très résistante en
défense baptême premier fils et qui
revient en d5 à être défend bien
elle défend bien à ricard
elles résistent elles résistent bien à
les h4
elle fixe attentionné sait si ce qui va
arriver un jour ou l'autre
la foire se méfier l ami laurent h3
j'aime bien ce qu'elle vient de faire à
rica le roi qui est beaucoup plus en
sécurité le lait il n'y a pas de pièces
qui peuvent le toucher
il n'y a pas de cavalier il ya rien qui
rôde
elle va vouloir tenir la position à il
faut vraiment qu'elle qu'elle tienne
c'est si on prend puis on prend ce qui
est b6 tour bouge savais que si la dame
réussi à venir à sète après et qu'elle
joue pour tours à deux mais d'un autre
côté elle a réussi à mettre son roi à
l'abri ce qui lui laisse un peu de temps
qu'elle a peut-être tour à 3
mais j'aime pas je sai d'espérer pourra
réclamer à la dame qui arrivant à 7
il y aura cinq qui va être en sous
pression il ya tour à deux quand même
qui va faire mal même si ça fait pas
mates ça ça ouvre des perspectives aux
noirs et ce cavalier on lui trouve pas
de bonnes cases
il arrive pas angers 5 et on sait pas
trop où il va alors la dame à 7k et c8
et peut-être prendre en d6 repartir vers
8 faire quelque chose comme ça allait
donc
saddam c7 ok peut-être mieux puisque du
coup elle protège le pion et à l'attack
le cavalier c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de
dames b2 donc ces cinq c5 bien jouer
puis on prend ses seins qu'elle veut
rebondir en 17 puis peut-être ans et
5.165 tour bien et maintenant damas sept
cavaliers c8 qui est des 6 suivi de
tourbe et ça et elle trouve du contre
donc dams est elle veut s'en prendre à
ce pion la sueur d'amy adams et de ja
pion aux trois qui tombe donc tour c'est
à sk d'autres options
kéhi ses huit direct et sur dame
français 5 quelle est l'idée tour 17
alors elle joue pour quoi elle joue bien
ça pour pas grand chose un ok elle joue
pour dames b21 peut-être dames c'est un
pour les pour les noirs peut-être dames
c'est un c empêche dame b2 et ça prépare
des trucs méchant sur la première dame
séance à une bonne gueule un dame prend
3 c'est une bonne gueule aussi puisque
sur d'armé de yahvé y avait des armes
pranger 3 maths et eau qui est juste là
il faut avoir calculé quelque chose
roy g8 ok sur échec à foix fuite et le
cavalier en diagonale par rapport aux
fous donc tu auras rien est sûr cavalier
e 8 y aura rien non plus donc cavalier à
vii ingénieux de la barbarie calvet
cavaliers g5 et tours b 8
donc là on peut voir des trois tours b 8
x fuite cavalli e6 d2 il ya peut-être un
père pète entre son cavalier 6 forcé à
cavaillon 6 3 et 7
cavalia fuite des deux et c'est fini et
oui ces rois f7 qui fait toute la
différence parce que 46 des deux tours
est fluide ça ça une gueule de perpète
voire même qu'un mayroy f7 d'abord
c'est exactement ce qu'elle a trouvé et
ça s'est fini tour des huit tours des
trois ris zain america qui va tourner à
-2 arica qui va tourner à moins 2 là
c'est sûr les amis ça ne peut pas en
finir entre man et très bien joué de la
part des li na et je crois que c'était
la dernière partie de 5 + 1 donc pour le
moment et lina qui domine écoutant à se
mettre une petite page de pub et on
revient dans cinq minutes
[Musique]
par les mecs ça va bientôt reprendre
donc on remet les caméras et c'est
reparti donc c'est la joueuse arménienne
danielian qu'ils allaient blanc elle
mène de deux points elles dominent le
match pour le moment de la tête et des
épaules
est-ce que ça va continuer honnêtement
je pense que oui après je peux me
tromper un bien évidemment c'est pas un
match on peut on peut pas la donner plus
de 70 75 % de chances à la joue et
arménienne de gagner mais
[Musique]
les d'après moi les quand même devant
dans ce match et je la vois bien
l'emporter mais après voilà c'est un
pronostic personnel
elle joue un peu mieux elle défend un
peu mieux elle est un peu mieux dans
tous les compartiments du jeu sauf
peut-être l'ouverture mais avec en plus
la séquence de bullet à venir
l'ouverture ça a baissé en importance a
réussi ce qu'on peut entreprendre tour d
un vrai bon ça va pas être ouais non ça
va pas casser trois pattes à un canard
ça c'est sûr jus qui n'ont que deux
pattes est vrai que daniel yankee qui
peut-être même favori tu speech at elle
fait une forte impression
elle fait une forte impression à la
battu la favorite elle a battu la
favorite du tournoi qui était katyal
haguenau est elle en train de dominer
arica qui avait fait un bon match contre
contre marie est réelle et non elle fait
vraiment forte impression il n'y a rien
d'autre à dire
pascal a fait retour des 1 dames des
cinq échecs peut-être bien jouer et
d'apprendre et 8 maintenant l achat
scelleront h ou huit
c'était bien vu et maintenant si un jour
elle fait du cavalier g5 ou quoi elle
regagnera un temps et e4 à s est très
bien joué là ce que vient de faire la
joueuse armenian et maintenant peut-être
un coup comme tour d un qui va arriver
ouais fou g4 sûrement ouais non marica
qui joue bien qui se défend pas mal h3
de m'apprendre f3 maîtres lecavalier ont
des cadres j'imagine j'imagine je sais
pas ok bref trois points f3 et cavaliers
des 4 ça sent quand même être l'option
donc et des cats pas forcé de le faire
tout de suite d'un autre côté on a le
temps de prendre les trois points je
crois qu'il y avait carrément des gardes
on est là elle pouvait le faire direct
mais elle pouvait aussi attendre
éventuellement mais ok crise prises et
foule cinq ans avec les c'est fou j'ai 4
c'était peut-être pas c'est peut-être
pas idéal
en tout cas maintenant le fou noir qui
va arriver à eux cinq leroy qui va
monter vers 6-7 la tour qui pourra l'on
ait fui doublé sur la colonne f et le
pion de 4 qui va être complètement
bloquée c'est peut-être même un poil
plus agréable maintenant pour les noirs
elle fait aux 5 du coup elle se
débarrasse du pion elle va prendre 17
elle remettra le fou en dessin qu'elle
va jouer un peu l'activité
c'est plutôt bien joué je trouve elle
laisse pas à arica s'installer sur
l'échiquier elle contre immédiatement et
elle prend tout de suite tout de suite
tout de suite les devants pour garder
l'activité alors elle se concentre
d'envoi la concentration ce visage des
deux joueuses areca qui a l'air un peu
je suis pas un clown triste j'ai
l'impression est forcément concentré
tour f 7
alors comment est ce que les noirs garde
l'activité il feint contre l'activité
des blancs ici et réussissent à faire à
profiter de leurs pions de plus à faire
fructifier cet avantage matériel fou dès
6 heures là je pense que l'idée c'était
touret fuite parce qu'il y avait le
clouage maintenant il n'y est plus
et donc escale mais moi sur pioncer 5,4
points à 7 sur fous ces cinq peut-être
alors pour protéger mes atouts reprend
là est donc là les blancs menaces qu'on
des quatre tours h4 et kef sûrement
faire tous réfutent allait faire un nul
je vois pas du tout comment est ce que
les noirs peuvent faire mieux que sa
tête ya moyen doit réunir tout reprend
dé 4,7 alors entrer en ce2 et jouer
l'attaqué non c'est pas idiot et retour
aux 8
c'est pas bête du tout c'est pas bête du
tout parce que quand la tour vian hk tu
auras toujours h5 et ça donnera un petit
temps de répit et pour le moment les
blancs réussissent pas assurés c'est la
tour étant des ceintures et mat avec
pour preuve cette qui arrive mais les
blancs réussissent pas à faire ça donc
il joue fouet f3 et la joueuse aérienne
qui renouvelle la menace sur le pion des
4 tout en empêchant tout re 2 donc faut
5 protège le pion maintenant est ce
qu'on peut faire partir le pion détroit
n'ont probablement la tour reviendra en
dix-sept même et le pion sera arrêté
donc fou des six tour odéon et les noirs
qui ne vont pas réussir à mon avis à
faire mieux que nul à moins qu'elles
jouent tour des huit ans premiers mois
elle fait des trois étangs 17 je pensais
parce que la food & cie ce tour des as
ou tour f1 même tu peux aussi et salto à
nantua fin dans lequel fc 5 et tout
repenser cette sarraut des malappris
détroit plutôt ça va échanger mais ça
veut dire que les noirs peuvent mettre
une pression du coup bien joué de la
part d'arica non roigé s'être
f 6 h 5 g 5 kg 4 on va essayer d'avancer
un maximum
camille le pion à 5 tours des cinq tours
j'ai cinq échecs probablement non tour
f5
alors maintenant faut remettre la marche
avant avec les pions avant c'est ok mais
ça c'est nul direct pour que cinq noms
vient [ __ ] couloir opposé semblait
assez annulant puisque tu pouvais mettre
le pion à 4 c'était nul automatique
étrange de ne pas avoir échangé parce
qu'on sait que ces finales avec tours
fou contre tours elles peuvent être plus
difficile à défendre
lorsqu'il ya encore les tours sur
l'échiquier sans les tours c'est nul
automatique
hélas elle perd là tout en un la gaffe
incroyable quand même ne pas avoir
échangé les tours vraiment à ce niveau
c'est quand même une faute parce que tu
fais juste à catane vous qui reste sur
la diagonale ceux qui ont fait le le
stage à budapest l'ont forcément vu avec
nous avec femmes on avait vu avec un
pion - final le fou de couleur opposée
si tu peux défendre tu étais pions sur
l'ale sur une des 2 à la stella la dame
vous pouvez faire à 4 du coup tu défends
tranquillement de l'autre côté avec le
roi et c'est une nulle automatique donc
c'est déjà étrange cette proposition des
changes de tours est encore plus et
chants plus étrange le refus et et la
tour qui est tombé en un de manière
assez assez inexpliqués inexplicables
donc une grosse gaffe de la part des li
na qui relance
arica dans le match mais ont vite
devenir double gaffe un quelque part
j'ai même envie de dire une double gaff
gaff stratégique et grave des gaffes
traque tactique après le c1 le truc de
finale de foot couleurs opposées
c'est juste qu'elle n'a pas réagi assez
vite donc prises des 5 prises des 5 soir
tout comme détroit maintenant dam des
trois tours c'est en tête dame b3 direct
sur foot prend des deux tours d un et on
va aller encaisser en d5 arica qui me
semble avoir une bonne position
il ya ricains qui veut me faire mentir
des quatre questions bessette est tabou
parce qu'ils la tour b 8e faire juste
pour ses reins pour ces deux tours c'est
un et les blancs au kef x 3 x 3 c'est
pas bête elle se débarrasse de son
mauvais fou cavaliers 4 fou prend
cavaliers alors d'apprendre dame prend
17 tours b 8 et enfermement de dames ou
pas y'a dame c6 quand même ce que le
pion était prenable discutable je vais
mettre un petit coup d'ordi parce que je
suis curieux le pion était prenable
tourabi huit dames cécile c'est bien ce
que je pensais le pion n'était pas
taboue n'était plus taboue
elle a commencé par tours fc 1 dames b6
et malin peut-être un petit coup de
dames 3 suivi tour b 1 dames qui
pourrait jaillir en f4 un jour alors
prise prises pour pourrir la structure
de pions mais maintenant le petit
problème des blancs c'est ce pion à 2
alors peut-être tour csn c'est l'idée de
d'arica qu'elle commence par f3 latu
version qui décide pour revenir vers ses
quatre peut-être cette même idée de
jouer des 5 et cavaliers c4 pour bien
installer le cavalier comme il faut et
s'en prendre aux cavaliers adverse tour
à 4 c'est pas mal joué elle n'a pas pris
le pion bessette et du coup la position
des blancs alors pas dire qu'elle est
fragile mais f6 face le cavale car elles
étaient trois et peut-être du fouet f5
intermédiaire kg cadets maintenant il va
au lieu de la prise pour le pion dessin
il va être un peu faible mais
mais on peut quand même prendre et faire
cavalier ou 4 par exemple ou peut-être
même ton compte 3 auquel fâche 5l c'est
possible aussi elle peut mettre le
cavalier ans et quatre cavaliers 3 après
les blancs là qu'ils se sont très mal
débrouillé elle était bien et elle se
retrouve sous pression pour eux deux
malheureusement être prendre quatre à
elle réussi à jouer quatre donc est-ce
qu'elle va réussir à renverser la vapeur
parce que sur quelles preuves katia tour
eu de maintenant qui veut peut-être sur
le clouage et quand même les caïds et 6
le retour du coup pas si évident que ça
parce que carey lieu quatre tours eux
deux ils accueillent des six amis à
peut-être qui prend 4 fou prend 4 mai
aux réfugiés si ce retour on pas claire
mais les noirs qui gagne le pion des 4
elle reprend b6 et tour des 2,5 à l'idée
des énarques des tours s'est vite pour
ces deux pour rentrer sur la deuxième
rangée est resté venir danser avec est
ici quatre carrés lieu trois ans elle
prend le cadre du club tuera pas été
protégé prise prise prise surtout re 1
ok mais surtout ses six on peut prendre
et prendre
ok mais surtout un atout reprend j'ai
deux échecs pardon donc pas jouable fou
f1
et maintenant comment est ce que les
noirs vont progresser ils peuvent faire
tour ses huit tours ces deux tours prend
h deux tours h un math donc les blancs
vont devoir déstabiliser le fou mais ça
écoeurant f5 pour le maintenir
toi un f5 le pion va être le four est
maintenu mais il y aura toujours eu deux
allées tour de mes tours deux tours d un
avec qui des tours c'est un fou détroit
ouais c'est difficile roi f2 peut-être à
jouer
alors sur foot est roi qu'est ce qui se
passe tout re un tour ces deux et ça
peut transposer dans des finales de
pions perdante
ce qu'il peut y avoir un truc qui se
fait flouer eu 2 to qui s'échangent en
e2 et g5 qui gagne donc elle s'en rend
compte à rica avec les blancs elle va
prendre en dix-sept maintenant il faut
prendre 2 2 quand même
enfin je crois vous prend 1,2 et tours
d2 et les blancs qui vont sûrement joué
roi de trois attaques et la tour avec
l'idée de faire fou prend h5 au prochain
sa part est hyper logique est pas fou
prend h5 you ici qui tombe fou b5
évidemment tout reproche de on imagine à
5 à 6 et le roi qui va aller vers
peut-être un petit coup droit f4 à un
moment donné j'aurais thierry fiat t3h6
ici bien jouer pour faire g6
mais tous rêvent de riches parce que toi
des échecs 3g 5
ok mais tu es tour ces trois alors torah
c'est un corps ça honnêtement je n'ai
pas très bien compris
foot est roi j'aime bien s'en prend
immédiatement but est peut-être manon
roy h6 quand même avec l'idée g5 les
blancs qui réussissent pas à créer de
vraies menaces malheureusement pour ça
qu'elle envoie le pion à 7 comme ok sur
tours à 8 à la ok mais l'aura jamais le
temps de mater en fait j'avais dit
retour b8 niera toujours g5 le cas
échéant
ok c'est pas mal tourbe et 6 échecs
maintenant il ya paroisse g5 ok très
bien joué de la part d'arica qui va de
nous voir naquet et sauver annuler l as
a pas été bien gérée il y avait du g5 à
mon avis avait quelque chose à faire et
arica qu'a réussi à arnaquer sap a été
bien gérée du tout parlé noirci soir
à mon avis avait un g5 échec à faire à
un moment donné pour chasser le roi et
je pense pas que les que les blancs et
puis faire grand chose qu'à arica tiare
nac et qu'il reste à flot bien joué de
sa part elle reste à 6,5 elles restent
elles restent proches elles restent
proches à reste collé à son adversaire
elle a qu'un point d'écart alors m
interesse visite chez sa even think that
life without chez six matches marine
christine gagnon évincé du beausset
dubos danielyan luis clavis ans en échec
est plus intéressante que la vie avec
échec donc savoir là c'est vérifiable
après c'est pas faux erika qui me
passionne une motivation nice to be
myself and i spy rauser est vrai mais
les suisses parce qu'elle nous inspire
mais en tout cas j'espère qu'elle vous
inspire bonne joueuse d'échecs elle joue
vraiment un bon niveau et on retrouve
les deux joueuses sur les caméras avec
les petits yeux ronds de arica les
grands yeux elle est même mieux que
quand j'ai beaucoup dormi et je suis en
forme
syl c'est moins joli que le match de
maradiva ça joue moins bien aussi un
donc donc donc qui sait 4,6 on voit la
différence sur les lots de chasse comme
le match de mardi
c'était c'était serré et j'ai déjà
oublié le nom des deux joueurs
c'est un speech s junior et c'était le
wonder li yang contre glay dur arrêt
mais c'est beaucoup plus fort alors
qu'est en d1 ça échange ces petites
position semi insipide
sa caricature joue pas mal hein la joue
pas mal glissé avec moroni awa pas je
pense que moroni joue beaucoup mieux que
les deux joueuses après face apparemment
il s'est un peu fait marcher dessus mais
je pense qu'ils gagneraient le match
contre l'une ou l'autre normalement ça
devrait pas durer très longtemps
comme dirait mur face
d'un des deux s'en prend aux cavaliers
f4 tout vêtement et les noirs qui
doivent choisir g5 pourrait être une
idée mais ça donne la case f5 et ça ça
se
il ya peut-être du g3 quelle phase iii
donc elle laisse le pion mais elle veut
prendre en g2 ça j'aime bien j'ai trois
cavaliers g2c j'ai tout de suite pensé
qu'elle voulait faire ça passe comment
elle va déstabiliser le cavaly c4 et
j'ai tout de suite senti cette histoire
de cavaliers g2 et son cavalier
installant au g2 il peut être pénible
genre sur cavaliers ou trois je vais
peut-être flash 6 et c'est vrai que ce
pion h3 il peut être fort
c'est intéressant en tout cas après sa
double tranchant parce que c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant mais le
pion elle va le perdre
d'ailleurs il est perdu et maintenant
focale et de l'activité elle fait foulée
3 ça c'est bien joué 5 elle récupère le
pion donc c'est des pions doublé mais
mais elle est fou qui découpe
est-ce qu'il ya la reine francophones en
parler du switch à seulement si on peut
mettre la reine francophones en
parallèle du speech est d'ailleurs très
bonne idée des tannes je vais
l'organiser tout de suite
désolé pour le petit à 25 minutes on va
mettre aujourd'hui on va mettre 20h30 et
on va mettre à rennes
alors s'est créé un match mas je me suis
planté tournoi à rennes à rennes
francophone chaise comme tv france
standard 5 minutes
aujourd'hui 21h30 et durer une heure
allez hop c'est parti je vous met le
lien dans le chat si vous voulez
participer à la en 21 heures 30 ces
20h30
pardon je faire une troisième tentative
de création du tournoi tournoi en club
début 20h30
aujourd'hui cas dans 5 minutes standard
cesse comme telle et france arena
francophones à rennes
durée 1h et le lien il va être donc
cette position
g4 intéressant ce soir ce qui a fait un
fouet fuite fous ces cinq dames v6 3,6
peut-être le retour peut arriver elle
fait cavalier 5 direct c'est intéressant
ça va prendre de j'imaginerais tatev si
si si important fois je 6e beaucoup
l'attention adam 17 tout de même d'un
prend b2 roi h3 faut quand même faire
gaffe fois je cite je vais bien mais le
problème c'est comment il ya plus à fils
il ya quand même fou prend aux cinq des
huit dames h8 maths qui rôde
donc elle revient avec le fou est
peut-être maintenant roi h3 et pénible
parce que sur dame prend b2 d'emprunt f7
c'est un peu payé on n'a pas d'âme des
uns pascal adam qui protège donc
peut-être à trois bien joué puis on
prend et d'ambea maintenant elle fait un
français soit ici et sur dame premier
set qu'elle est l'idée adam point f3
mesdames g63 schwyz dame hui 3 mhz
hamdami sirois schwyz et bien joué et ça
va faire une nouvelle nul ça va faire
une nouvelle nul toujours un point
d'avancé pour la joueuse arménienne
toujours un point d'avancé
on a de nouveau ce gambie dame soit
c'est accepter hybride mais le pion qui
vient pas en d4
donc c'est pas un gambit dames francesca
8 bis parties nulles cette partie nulle
sur douze sur douze parties à beaucoup
de nuls en dans ce match mais s'est joué
ce qui joue très stratégique qui
prennent pas trop de risques dans les
milieux de jeu et qui rate un peu d
occasions tactique on en a vu
quelques-unes
c'est vrai il y avait eu un cavalier
prend qu'elle prend g3 mon début de
match et on avait vu une ou deux autres
occasions apprendra aussi vu danielian
raté une nulle d'être ça s'équilibre
dans le fond en tout cas on a cette
nouvelle position qui ressemble un peu à
des slaves et gambit dames et attention
parce que les blancs menace peut-être
cavaliers propositions progressistes
vous prend aussi ce roi bouge et non sa
menace pas pascal cas au lycée 3 qui
empêche de faire la découverte et
surtout prend aussi surprendre si ce qui
est pris aussi c'est pas assez de
matériel donc sa menace pas mais eux
quatre menaces peut-être un peu 5
maintenant ou menace est qui prend pions
prend fou prend roi bouger e5 chasserait
lecavalier gagnerait 17 donc le 4 crée
une menace est là qui reprend ainsi sa
marche non vous c'est moi qui hallucine
puis on prend fou prend aussi c'est fou
prend 17 est donc allé pas du tout vu le
le truc à 1 kg 5 généralement et qui a
eu 5 ajoute ou tempo derrière mais
c'était pas si mauvais incroyable
mais là ya pas qu elle prend des cinq
étrangers 5 à incroyable ouais ça la
fait craquer ça l'a fait tilter
incroyable mais d'un pays qui est promu
6-5
s'il a tout vu tempo c'est très très
très bien joué
qui prend h7 kiev karaté c'est qu'elle a
un petit avantage le dernier lorsqu'elle
peut trouver truc tempo des fois très
bon mais réfléchir longtemps pour
d'autres trucs est là c'est
problématique parce que la dame est bien
placé en b 8 jolie tactique donc ce pas
encore alors il ya deux pièces de moins
à la réaliser quand même pas mal
d'activités pour la pièce elle s'en est
bien tiré mais là il ya deux pièces au
caire tente et dames chez 3 adam qui
travaillent qui avaient lieu deux pas le
temps de faire maths qu'elle veut faire
d'alger 3 mai dans mes deux pièces ses
chars
une seule pièce non à deux pièces un
accord voulais me rendre chèvre à la
cave a lui aussi ça mon avis ok tout
reprend aussi danielian qui reprend deux
points et je trouve que ça là elle fait
mal parce que cavaliers pro 6 est
incroyable elle avait et ce qu'elle
avait si elle avait vu et qu'elle a fait
ça pour s'activer c'est quand même super
bien joué c'est quand même super bien
joué
si c'était volontaire c'est super bien
joué donc une moderne où on en a en
termes de temps 33 min dont il reste il
reste cinq parties en trois plus un il
ya deux points d'écart pas énorme ça se
remonte mais on sent qu'elle a réussi
par cole est un non sens qu'elle a du
mal à recoller au score face à la
joueuse
enfin la face à jose arménienne qui est
quand même très dominante
si on regarde sur le match dans les
positions serré celle qui a fait des
petites différences donc
ces quatre fous 3 et peut-être des 4 à 4
à 5 kits hippiques pour gagner l'espace
allait droit à la dame pardon et les
noirs vont devoir jouer à l'ailé droit
cas il est précis sur flu g4 jetez un
oeil à notre aréna que deux inscrits à
l'aréna francophone pour le mans salem
monsieur p soit g4 se répète très bon
mais je sais pas pourquoi c'est à tour
des huit détroit
triste espace a eu lieu il faut faire un
truc pour les noirs 7g 5g canon je sais
pas sur un peu trop impulsif avec les
noirs personnellement elle voulait qu'un
maillage trois échecs peut-être pas
vraiment réussi un truc quelque chose
gâche 5 elle envoie un peu mieux 3
menace de revenir vers des cinq mais pas
pour le moment la case des cinq est bien
couverte un château gérante a plutôt
fait cette prise d espace là tu peux
faire des cinq même peut-être x 3 pour
chasser ou fou b2 pour essayer de jouer
sur le pion j'ai l'impression que là
c'est plutôt à rica qui a des
convictions quand elle fait d'alger
simple qu'en plus elle menacera cavale
et h3 qui prend f2 mais bon il y aura
cavaliers froid sur dame g5 donc rien
d'inquiétant pour les blancs non plus
hein c'est solide fois justice j'aime
bien ça active le fou qui faisait rien
sur le diagonal salut ak steel chess
carélie c4 alors à 6,7 peut faire b5 b4
chasser le pion et le week-end des 4
j'aime bien la manière de jouer d'arica
ici les blancs qui partent pour les
échanges des cinq bien joué si la tour
prend elle reprendra de la dame
j'imagine ce qui lui permettra de jouer
sur la colonne d ela j'imagine des 4
c'est peut-être de faire dame des quatre
aussi un jour là cavalier prend et d'amd
quatre probablement cette lame peut
revenir un jour en a
fois fuite des cinq succès dans des
cartes d'amd caldara ça me plaisait un
but tout à l'heure mais fou b4 qui est
ici qu adam des cats peut-être très dam
des cas peut-être le cas les parties en
f3 rey et du coup sûr damman peut-être
d'âme des uns et ça me n'est pas grand
chose quoique bon alors il faut attaquer
côté noir alors belfond 10,6 soit donc
fou b4 c'était vraiment pas le coup de
l'année est maintenant peut-être une
idée ces dames à huit dames à troyes où
damas huit damas pour aller récupérer
les pions à 9,6 alors peut-être grillage
trois échecs est une menace si on prend
et d'emprunts f3c des deux dames f6
elle a du mal à danielian à défendre
haut quelle idée sur calais h3c d'avoir
droit à agen et que le pion à f2 soient
protégés par la dame
donc j'ai cinq ans elle veut g4 peut
quand même faire j'ai quatre je pense et
reprendre du pillon f pour contrer un
tas de cases importante tout cas elle
met la pression
allez il faut vraiment qu elles
l'emportent dans cette partie arica
c'est important pour coller au score
tout à fait rage 3 1 ghz et 2 vient
jouer ce qu'elle n'a pas un peu laissé
échapper sion aussi s'il était pas si
mal placé un là du coup le pion à f/5
des blancs est plutôt pas mal et la
partie qui a peut-être un peu tourné
carénage trois rois j'ai deux pions l'a
aidé à me 4 maintenant peut-être way le
pion g4 sceaux sous pression dames g5
sept cavaliers f1 ou d'un projet 5
intermédiaire mais oui mesdames 3 1
dames pro f 5
il faut j'imagine non elle fait pas
devait y avoir un problème où elle veut
faire d'un match 3 mai d'un match quand
ça va pas aller bien loin
la dame arrive en d5
ça m'a l'air d'être un problème pour
harry qu'à frangy 1 dames h5 le retour
on imagine
pas évident à jouer faux 5 stamm des 5
fu et six jurés fils me paraît
impossible adam g 8 3 et 6 la remarque
c'est peut-être là qu'il faut qu'à rica
tente quelque chose qu'il n'y a plus de
temps pour son adversaire
allez c'est bien ce qu'elle fait le fou
indécis ce qui peut menacer de venir en
c5
mais maintenant il ya b6 très bien joué
de la part de daniel yon où là il ya du
dame croit y avait d'ailleurs m attends
de là les mecs là ma tondeuse sur
d'arracher ces dames pro f 7 et dames g8
matti était ratée il ya eu ma temps de
rater allez faire d'un me 4 l'afutt
couleur opposée elle est pas si clair je
crois qu'il m'a tant de rater je suis
pas sûr après un fort et que je puisse
revenir mais je crois bien la dame prend
f5 nom d'un preuve cinq échecs pas jouer
ce ne sont pas jouables ici ok mais là
y'a m'attendais mais cette dame g6 et
m'attend na waie est plutôt je crois
qu'elle a raté un vraiment d'un match
s'il devait y avoir des recettes
bon alors ça fait plus 3
et ça commence à faire cher là parce que
arica qui avait pas une mauvaise
position qui une nouvelle fois à un poil
vendanges haye et elle a un poil
vendanges aie aie aie ça fait plus trois
pour danielian et +3 ça devient sérieux
+3 ça devient plus difficile à remonter
les amis on s'inquiète un peu pour la
joueuse
indienne c'est quand même mal
il reste quoi il reste 24 minutes à
jouer dans le 3 + 1 et après on aurait
la bulle et bullet qu'apparemment
cassill chaise dans le chat aime
beaucoup d'heures si vous êtes ici pour
la première fois ou si vous n'avez pas
encore fait n'hésitez pas à cliquer sur
le petit bouton follow poursuivre la
chaîne ça fait toujours plaisir et ça
vous permettra de suivre les prochaines
demi finale qui sera je crois le 23 donc
dimanche et le dernier match qui sera la
finale qui sera le 27
le 27 donc le 23 mai ce sera bien
dimanche 23 et le 27 ce sera jeudi
prochain
arman je pense qu'à ce jour là qui a
démonté d'audace matin en stream je
pense que faire quelque chose avec les
grands il peut hein
il peut après ça dépend aussi de l'état
de motivation de toda c'est jamais
facile à savoir saïfi rhodia qui passent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
jouer aux échecs que ce soit en bullet
en bis ou quoi sur internet pas ça fait
un peu que ça et tout âge je pense y
faire un peu moins d'échecs dont
peut-être il joue un peu en peu plus en
dilettante mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est ce que me disait bladder j'avais
plein de téléphone il était tellement
important de d'énormément aimé les
échecs 1 ont donné pour pour devenir
champion du monde doit être dans les
tous meilleurs et ça peut faire la
différence de taille les gens qui aiment
plus ses échecs que d'autres et c'est
vrai que ça ça peut ça peut faire une
différence après entre autres
quelqu'un qui va plafonner à 2007 2007
dit c'est quelqu'un qui va arriver à à
27 50 27 27 81 ça peut ça peut être une
ça peut être un facteur important mais
cette discussion un peu au sujet des
candidates
il fait que c'était peut-être plus
facile de de bien jouer quand tu es
vraiment de ta vie que que des échecs
exclusivement donc j'étais juste ont dit
oui que peut-être que duda je sais pas
je crois qu'il a une vie plus bas à
charger ses panneaux mais plus
diversifiée donc quand il joue le matin
sur chaise comme est ce que il est
vraiment motivé à voir c'est quoi ton
truc pour éviter d'autres souffrent des
fourchettes de kayonza it not a parlé
la couleur des cases loyal à focale ya
les cases en diagonale et les casses
proches en fait un cavalier
je vais prendre celui là il a du mal à
aller là et il a du mal à aller là
déjà il s'était sur une casse comme ça
tu es un peu tranquille c'est ça qui a
aidé 2 4 kg 4
alors cette position qu est ce que ça
donne piaf ou des deux fous des quatre
fers tour à 2
je pense que je préférais les blancs et
comme la paire de fou le pion c6 qui est
bien défendu s'ils ont réussi à
s'organiser un peu à taper sur ces 7 ou
à quatre ça peut être sympa mais
s'inclinant aussi des des arguments à
faire valoir
franchement c'est pas évident à évaluer
s'inclinant aussi le fou qui tapissent y
danse est très difficile à évaluer en
fait je passe que vous pensez de ce
match les amis je passe s'il vous plaît
ou pas devrait pas très actif dans le
tchat ce soir ce qui tend laisse à
penser que vous n'êtes pas passionné par
le match 3 pour ses cinquièmes et bien
vu de la part de daniel yon elle va
réussir à mettre la pression sur le pion
à 3 et sur le pion à eux deux et sur le
pion ces six arrêts c'est super bien
joué
hélas le fouet tous ces clowns à aimer a
été transféré tout bêtement à arica qui
a craqué or elle a su et j'ai
l'impression qu'à ricains craque
complètement dans ce match sous les
coups de butoir de danielian qui est en
train de faire l'écart qui est en train
de faire l'écart lie à +4 les amis et on
ne voit même plus les yeux d'arica les
yeux ont disparu et lina trop forte
levin hacker qui est au dessus ouais là
là là on l'a senti un peu au dessus
pendant tout le match
sauf fait deux trois premières parties
m'apprend l'a senti au dessus et c'est
maintenant que c'est en trace de se voir
au score on sait qu'il fabrique d'une
minute est je pense à l'ina un but que
vieirinha pardon vu comment elle joue là
je pense qu'elle est favorite elle m'a
l'air de mettre la pression sur
l'adversaire petit à petit et j'ai cette
vague impression que
carrick a est dans le dur et c'est très
très très difficile de sortir la tête
dans ces cas là c'est vraiment compliqué
une fois que tu une fois que tu as
commencé à te faire dominer de la sorte
dans ces matches là c'est très compliqué
de revenir dans le match
c'est très compliqué de revient dans le
match
alors est ce que c'est moi où il ya des
petits fils rouges sur la caméra d'arica
arica qui sut well as eu et on sait pas
ce que c'était les petits fils rouges
en tout cas elle a su et ses cheveux on
n'aura plus que les cheveux d'arica 3es
lignes en toge sais pas s'ils ont foutu
ouais c'est vrai que la seule la force
du gange peu peut mettre peut remettre
la joueuse indienne dans le match c'est
vrai qu'avec le gange avec à l'aide
pourrait revenir mais ça va être
difficile quand même
il faudrait un gant jungle contrôler le
gange
la force du vent je peux peut être un
peu un peu juste peut ne pas suffire à
les cavaliers qui s'approche droit mais
le fond f1 qui défend bien
il va y avoir du g3 le fou qui va
revenir en g2 peut-être et encore quatre
après mais bon accueil qui amènera
peut-être f6 bref 4 elle va reprendre 2e
peut-être elle fout qu'il va revenir
vers ses quatre et qui va menacer le
pion avec peut-être des idées de jf si
on prend d'alger 6 donc elle empêche à 4
qui installe le fou est peut-être
maintenant la dame qui va venir danser
par ici dames 2 sacré pas vraiment de
menaces peut-être un petit coup de hache
quatre voies autour des 8 pour des huit
tours des inrocks avaient tout échanger
et au pire prendre nul c'est vrai
qu'elles dominent le match il ya quatre
points d'écart conséquent bullet ya une
dizaine de partis donc si tu tournes à
+4 tu peux perdre le match de bullet
trois et demi 6 ennemis
ça laisse quand même un sens une
certaine marge surtout que dans ses
positions la égale arica un peu pas
égales quasi égale garric a un peu
craqué dames 8
on peut faire tout reprendre et un tour
prend des seins et dames 7 et tout est
changé
ça semble être possible
fait tour 17 il faut toujours faire
attention quand même un faute de ne pas
trop laisser le jeu à rentrer sajoo est
à double tranchant de la tour des
huîtres et une faute et à tour un échec
et mat s'accepter tel qui frappe en
premier
g3 et allez peut-être pour 17 maintenant
blanc qui doivent peut-être revenir avec
dame 8 loi comment colmater sa première
rangée dame prend et d'âme des uns et
venir essayer de choper espion faut
vraiment défendre ici côté côté et lina
mes tours d'essai n'était peut-être pas
le coup le plus le plus précis de
l'année
elle revient on défend un set et ben
entourent des 3l s'emmêler les pinceaux
avec tours 17 tours 7 ans a tout de
suite senti alors qu'elle va faire ses
cinq c4 mais les blancs qui vont avoir
le temps de s'emparer du pion f3 gagne
espions ça fait quand même une
différence parce que ce pion il était
quand même très très très pénibles
ah non elle va remettre la dame en d1
probablement dam des 2 tours 3 elle veut
faire b3 mais je joue pas mal arica mais
elle se plante à certains moments elle
fait des petites erreurs qui lui coûte
cher
m le plan b trois fours b1 est bien
bloqué le fou là bas allez il reste 50
secondes au noir 30 secondes aux blancs
comment lutter est ce que dame des
canons du genre de s'activer avec les
langues locales prend elle va faire b3
c'est vrai que c'est bien jouer au moins
le fou ces deux est bien placé qui va et
qui va réussir à tenir ça nul à mon avis
c'est vrai qu'elle a bien joué en
mettant pions b3 est très forte en
défense
si les noirs veulent l'emporter il va
falloir essayer de jouer sur la première
rangée
mais maintenant les blancs qui
réussissent à faire tour qui réussissent
à faire tour 3 m laurent h2 ou angers 1
à laisser si noir veulent l'emporter
peut-être tour des quatre tours d2 bien
joué et peut-être maintenant tour des
quatre faut être un peu malin là faut
créer de l'incertitude dame f3 s'est
très bien joué sur wife fayyad à machin
matt surprise prise fou des quatre
peut-être mais c'est un poil short on
menace rien
pour foot et 4 nages dames pranger 3
mais pas de plus fous ces trois dames d1
dames des 5es le pion qui arrive pas à
passer allez faut jouer plus vite
il faut jouer plus vite
la dame en juin mais elle va rien
menacée mais remarque damien fous ces
foules améliora dame f3 et elles gagnent
autant à on avait oublié le temps j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient plus de temps mais je
pensais qu'elle réussira à jouer et
arica qui recolle incroyable et lina un
peu lente est un peu lente
ouais
donc des cas ceux-ci samassa s'est pas
uni mesures non une anti nîmes zoé
savard tas peut retomber dans des
catalanes et on va retrouver dans des
structures de type est haut de ma roxy
merci à louga qui apparemment a bien
aimé la vidéo de la partie d'aaland sa
relance le match complètement areca gère
mieux son temps des équidés 5 voir jouer
avec vous et trois caïds et si ce samedi
coup de fouet trois pour menacer la dame
enfin ça doit exister un il faut 3 et
peut-être damas cinq espions c4est
emprise dame sait si ça me dit quelque
chose c'est vraiment là où il faut et
iii et iv dame c6 aussi d'ailleurs
excusez-moi j'ai raconté n'importe quoi
ce qu'elle sait pas fait magouilles avec
les noirs avec les blancs pardon noir
sans leur juste gagner un pion capa cup
je vais faire et c'est sur les idées 5
sapa font que je sais sur marché
d'utilité ça pour prisé dame prend mais
là le problème c'est que maintenant te
prendre du plomb ici à dresser la paix
msp est et ça c'est la vraie paix à
l'ess qui on prend à 5 qui arrive sur en
bessin qui ont france et 4 comprend ces
quatre fous b4 encore plus fort
intermédiaire menace des quatre et c'est
dommage costa rica c'est la deuxième
partie qu'elle donne juste c'est cadeau
alors là encore une micro chance de
tenir mais ces cadeaux de la part d'
harry cas c'est quand même dommage c'est
quand même dommage position qui est
complètement foutu mais avant il ya ces
trois fous bouge et ses deux échecs et
c'est fini le gros cadeau le gros gros
gros cadeau d'arica assez moche c'est
moche à l'abandonnent d'ailleurs mais
c'est moche parce que c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est pas noël quoi un
jeu hier on est en juin
c'est le 20 juin c'est pas la fête du
gange ce soir énorme cadeau de la part
d'arica incroyable les amis
incroyable quel cadeau étonnant la
joueuse indienne qui s'est planté
quelque part dans l'ouverture mais qui
s'est planté bien ce qui a valu à quatre
avec façon pas la tête du succès pas la
tête de l'emploi
et c'est et c'est une défaite qui coûte
incroyable c'est la fête du gange
c'est vraiment un cadeau c'est vraiment
un gros cadeau les amis et c'est assez
triste pour la joueuse indienne
ça fait quand même deux points 2-2 juste
données distribuées c'est la
distribution de poing américain qui
était fragile pour le moment dans ce
match et là il n'y a pas de nouvelle
partie qui démarre que se passe-t-il de
gestion photo y at il un bug par les
gars qui sue sur la photo on la sangsue
est non j'rigole elle susurre la caméra
un gros écart
il reste combien de temps il reste six
minutes dans cette classe sl fut minutes
dans cette cadence et c'est assez
dommageable pour pour arica tout de même
je vous remets l'alien de l'aréna si
vous voulez y participer
étonnant je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
après cette gaffe je vais essayer de
regarder sur mon téléphone voir s'il ya
des infos information s du match
je sais pas les amis en tout cas le
match semble je vais regarder comme ça
le match le match semble en suspens je
met les commentaires officiels
atteint d'un problème d'internet ya un
problème d'internet étonnant c'est pas
su pas exactement ce qui s'est passé
mais il ya un problème d'internet
apparemment et ça va repartir
alors est ce que je compte faire un bloc
en cave la de venir à cannes
ouais très possible
on verra sur malte on n'aura peut-être
pas le temps du tout en fait ça dépend
combien de temps on travaille mais si on
travaille bien peut-être pas du tout
avoir
c'est quoi la création du mondial et de
jose elles sont dans le top 20 mondial
ça c'est sûr bah quoi que non et lina
peut-être pas et moins bien qu'à ses
mairies cas c'est une des lois quinzième
mondiale quelque chose comme ça
quelqu'un peut peut-être chez qu'est
exactement les classements change
souvent avoir salu kiss kill
allez c'est reparti j'imagine qu'ils
vont laisser le temps filer comme ça qui
va ailleurs plus qu'une partie en trois
plus un de toute façon je pense quand
les deux cas de figure ça a été le cas
et c'est li na qui a les blancs à mon
avis si ça tourne à plus 4 + 5 pour elin
à ce sera quand même très difficile pour
arcade revenir 1 + 1 en revanche si
arica ghana et qu'elle revient à moins 3
tout est possible arica 14e mondial tu
vois j'ai dit 15e 14e sur qui
actifs/inactifs aussi en revanche et
lina qui doit bien plus loin mais qui
montre dans ce pitch est en tout cas sur
internet
elle est très forte ce qui a déjà grillé
les qualifs à la gagner le premier match
contre la championne du monde de blitz
khatir l'agglo et là elle domine face à
rica que aussi une des meilleures
joueuses de glisse du monde et on verra
bien ce que ça donne
elle jouera si elle se qualifie en
finale donc le demi finale c'est gomina
kosteniuk donc ce sera des gros morceaux
on verra ce que ça donne est ce qu'elle
est aussi solide en finale enfin si elle
joue contre queen à coup c'est mieux que
les deux sont vraiment très très forte
et si elles affichent le même niveau mon
avis elle peut faire mal tout comme cinq
ici va être possible peut-être pas se
presser avec les blancs le pion peut
devenir faible elle le fait j'aurais
hésité aussi c'est peut-être très bon 1
puisque quand tu commentes moi j'ai pas
le temps je peux pas calculé du tout le
5 tu prends de l'espace et tu te libères
la case de 4 pour le cavalier pour
éventuellement revenir vers des six
c'est logique
rien de plus logique que ça si on prend
elle à elle prend du cavalier même parce
qu elles provoquent un peu les échanges
en fait si lecavalier ce bar le cavaly
sera bien aux cinq et six cavaliers
prend on reprendra du pion et on se
libérera là car on aura la case 4 pour
le cavalier ou aussi la case f3 donc
c'est peut-être pas mal d'avoir échangé
une paire de cavaliers ici les cavaliers
blanc ce marché un peu dessus fou 17
prépare peut-être grand roque f4 protège
le pion est préparé
du cavalier sur la case e 4 le cavalier
qui va arriver en 4 qui menacent d'aller
en d6 a dû dames 3 ou d'un f2 du grand
roque qui arrive c'est quand même fou à
6 m
non c'est tout le match
c'est tout moi j'avais envie de me faire
plein là on est à deux heures trente de
commentaires j'ai envie de regarder des
trucs un peu fous fous je me fais
plaisir
elle fait grand roque et sur pions prend
1,5 peut-être comprend g5 avec le
cavalier qui bloquera les pions doublé e
et le fou g7 qui vivra pas si on
retrouve un truc comme ça
le pion aux 5 va boucher avis la vue du
fou g7 qui pourra pas sortir y avoir
beaucoup de mal à sortir ce fou il
serait vraiment emmuré dans ses pions
donc ça a continué par prisa à prendre
prendre prendrai peut-être dame eu cinq
échecs ici pour se remettre la bonne
structure et taper un peu sur le pion
aux 6 et c'est chose faite et lina qui
est de nouveau un peu mieux la tour qui
peut peut-être aller un an des six est
fou c'est 8 mai tour est fait un tour f6
idées pour s'en prendre aux pions h6 du
plu surtout reif 8
on peut prendre reprises et prendre ici
ça fait un pion de plus c'est vrai que
c'est des pions doublé mais comme dirait
mur tu as c'est par un pion de plus un
temps de plus parce que il te faut un
temps pour les manger cependant après
fou ou six tours 5 fu 17 prix des sept
échecs et tour ici un petit échec ici
c'est sur trois c'est 8 et elle fait roi
des deux est tourné ton g7 et là c'est
quand même avantage blanc il ya ce pion
plus qui fait quand tu fais tourner
autour des 2 tours pranger 2 du coup tu
gagnes pas le pion et ya la tour en
septième donc il va falloir voir pour
elina comment progresser mais elle a
clairement un petit avantage peut-être
même pas si petit que ça c'est quand
même plus en plus sur 7e art c'est des
pions doublé mais quand même quand on
est bien placé c'est assez agréable à
jouer pour les blancs cette histoire
comme sait capter 3 je dirais g4
pourquoi pas
elle peut avoir l'idée aussi tour ici
tour ici mais surtout ici pour le moyen
tour 4 donc peut-être roi des trois
tours ici qui peut être une vraie idée
et le plonger de on voit son utilité
c'est du coup le pion g5 sera pas passé
et donc ça va presser celle ci qu'il ya
une vraie menace commence par ces quatre
mais elle va faire tous rêvent 7
je suis en train de regarder 6e tour f
celle ci est vraiment un bon coup
toi ici va laisser la différence du pion
qu'elle a réussi à transformer les pions
doublé en un pion passé mais la tour g2
qui est bien placé
comment est-ce qu'on va progresser
peut-être que c'est quand même nul
peut-être est-ce quand même il ya échec
échec à la c'est bon c'est fini
j'allais faire à trois peut-être plus
tôt puisque échec échec échec et ça fait
nul et il semble que c'est et la
dernière partie parce qu'il ya écrit
time up à moins ce qui donne encore une
partie à elle c'est à dire qu'ils ont
arrêté le chrono tout à l'heure et il
donne encore une partie des sept minutes
et encore une partie à l'escale à jouer
avant tech
h3 ici ou cavaliers h3c kf3 laisse juger
quatre employés reste 2 minutes 40
ils ont raison coupée le temps alors
après moi choix pour qu'ils aient des
petites pauses parfois ok bon toujours
quatre points d'écart et arrêter avec
les blancs qui doit obtenir une victoire
ici recoller au score
un petit peu en tout cas
revenir à trois points importants pour
elle le gange et avec elle tout le gange
la soutient la joueuse indienne
cette dame 3 c'est chose faite elle se
tait cloud le cavalier peut-être un coup
comme carey lieu cinq maintenant on va
arriver mais le fou qui aurait pu même
type comme fou enfin non l échange
cette meilleure d'échangé c'est moi qui
craque un peu car il ya eu 5 et
maintenant ils peur des idées de radin
qu'ayant g5 une dame en h4 ce pion qui a
attaqué j'aime bien attaquer cogner des
pions doublé parce que du coup quand à
kadam h 4 kg 5 il ya plus de h6 pour
t'empêcher de venir là donc cavalier f3
peut-être quand même carélie g5 et
tarifs 4 d'un match 4 ans qu'elle joue
avec f4 mail il faut venir comme
s'attaquera f7 et tu vas aller mater en
force
elle peut gagner cette partie allait le
gange à l'esprit de wisches n'arrête
avec elle ou de vishnou de wisches
quelque chose
je kf3 le problème c'est être cavaliers
ou quatre en réalité qu'elle fait bécane
du coup et elle veut jouer pour
cavaliers b3 kaïs et 5 dans l'option est
attaqué je la regardais cavaliers prend
quand même pour apprendre un pro 6
cavaliers f3 ça pouvait être un une
possibilité à laquelle anne détroit qui
a aidé 2 qui est b3 caillaissé 5
skippy soit avec toi made in taïwan 3 4
et 5
taghli de faire cavalier à 6 et une
fourchette pour gagner du matériel des
noirs peuvent très bien prendre les
maîtres le carillon c41 d'ailleurs ce
serait une possibilité pour les noirs à
mon avis elle a bougé la dame est allée
vers h4 je vous les blancs peuvent
réagir par pierrot h2 moche et pas on la
veut faire d'un match 4 j'imagine mais
elle est partie pour ça tu menaces f4
seront pas trop de menaces pour les
blancs bref un tempo
8 chasse compliqué comme position
compliquée est-ce qu'elle va échanger le
truc c'est que la dame en h4 est bien
placé je pensais qu'ils allaient faire
rage 2 et g3 pour chasser la dame de cet
endroit là mais ça avait d'autres
inconvénients il prend prend prend aux
quatre cavaliers prend mais sur dame
prend b5 on imagine peut-être une tour
arrivant à 2 je vous disais ça çà çà çà
çà çà çà çà çà çà et ça je suis au pire
perpète
après je sais pas champion prend
peut-être plus fort au final puisqu'elle
joue peut-être pour gagner en fait tour
à 3 ces quatre juges avaient un peu ce
côté gestionnaire pour les noirs mais
c'est vrai qu'à la raison de mettre la
pression si elle pense être mieux avec
la dame en g3 est pénible cependant fait
ça m est bon même dame b 3 à tour ces
trois élèves non non non elle est bien
et tourbez droit pour qui l'avenir vers
le pion ça va échanger peut-être contre
le pion à eux
amir et tours b 2 ou pas à nous entourer
de sa menace qu'un tas de torrents b5 ce
que tourbe et deux sacrés pas de menaces
est plongé deux détenus et ça va faire
nul juste qu'ils peuvent accepter la
nulle la qualif on a pressé les noirs
qui se mit press
mais ça peut solder par une nulle rapide
cette histoire est donc ça tournera plus
4 ça tournera plus quatre chèques pour
revenir en c3 arica qu'on a jamais
réussi à faire fructifier ses avances au
temps et donc ça fait nul et je pense
bien cette fois ci que c'était la
dernière partie de la cadence et donc on
se retrouve les mecs dans 5 minutes pour
le dénouement du match en bullet on est
à égalité à quatre points d'écart
rien n'est fait il reste une dizaine de
partis
le gant je peux encore triomphé
[Musique]
parler
on est de retour pour cette dernière
phase de jeu j'ai allumé la lumière
il n'y a plus de lumière là c'est le
sehy faits sont là il fait sombre
on va mettre la lumière à fond en tout
cas ce qu'il en reste dans ce studio
comme je le disais c'est le dernier
stream ici normalement aujourd'hui à
moins de problèmes techniques
durant le week end mais ça devrait être
le dernier ici il me fait très plaisir
bien évidemment et donc la page de pub 7
la dernière dernière demi-heure de
stream dans ce studio les mecs ont envie
tout à l'heure la dernière vidéo avec
fab et là c'est la dernière dernière
demi-heure de 2,2 stream est ce que je
compte tout péter nan parce que je vais
en avoir besoin de mes choses je suis
pas comme moment un chef et un million
de vues je sais la publicité ne
rembourse pas mais mes cassage possible
du coup pas de partis pas au lit plat
est vite fait à ban on est jeudi du coup
du coup le jeudi pas de parti
pédagogiquement c'est lundi je crois et
pour le 3ème live d'échec dans la
semaine il va faire arriver aux 300 seul
donc pour le moment on est bloqué à deux
là il va en mode veille
pas de chance la chante la cara
peut-être d'autres live je dis pas mais
pas d'échec la chaise une page se tourne
ouais ouais fo ce bain salle des liens
sa machine vite stream
là on est en train de tomber sous les
200 seul donc dur on en est loin
pas de chance la france aura peut-être
d'autres la joie qui est un jeu de
tennis qui est sorti d'ailleurs
dernière savait par hambourg et vous
écoute je savoure à plus tard tête avec
le poker gerena du matos mais pour
autant la wii est peut-être salut qu'à
une vidéo pour l'ouverture de 4,5 avec
fracas et 6 bat on en a fait 3 avec fab
allez c'est parti pour le bullet les
amis
la joueuse arménienne danielyan avec les
pièces blanches
hélas non ce n'est pas parti parce que
là c'est trois minutes la sueur faux
départ faux départ les amis propose une
petite nul par accord mutuel
allez c'est parti les amis pour le
bullet danielyan l'arménienne avec les
pièces blanches qui a quatre points
d'avance face à arica poussé par tout le
gange le gange est derrière elle et on a
un gambit staunton le gambiste anton
donc c'était le coup eux quatre dans
l'eau landaise
c'est mon répertoire pour une fois il ya
des choses que je connais et les noirs
qui jugent et si je crois que c'est pas
super bien réputée dure un truc comme
fou prend un cavalier pro 4 ou peut-être
f3 qui comprend à quel point f3 je ne
sais plus l'un ou l'autre peut être même
les deux sont jouables est donc prise
dans le iv fou qui va venir en g7 où la
dame recettes ouais on met la pression
sur le cavalier et attention pas f 5e
rue du cavaliere six échecs peut-être
quoique ce n'est peut-être pas si grave
non plus mais fou g7 jouer grand roque
petit rock qui va arriver et donc on a
los cocos s'oppose à loos lez rock
opposé en français on parle un petit peu
espagnol dont ses lives attention et
donc cavalier trois oppositions un petit
peu étrange ses positions de hollandaise
gambie staunton parce qu'on a
l'impression avec les blancs qu'on a
plus de facilité à attaquer le roi noir
parce qu'il ya ces pions réussissez g6
qui sont un petit peu avancé mais on n'a
pas le fou de cases noires donc le fou
en g7 qui est assez serein
il est serein il est en défense il est
bien placé et les cavaliers blanc on
voit qu'ils tapent sur la muraille de
chine ou du coup la muraille du gange
donc c'est peut-être un petit ganges ici
sur la 5eme ranger et les cavaliers ne
peuvent pas rentrer 2
sue les noirs qui développe le fou
angers 4 le fouillant eu de cavaillé 17
alors peut-être qu'on veut aller
rebondir vers c4 est ce que le cavalier
va venir en blé si c'est une possibilité
c'est jouer maintenant
le cavalier qui va peut-être venir en c4
le pion à f5 pour ouvrir la diagonale du
fou
il y aura peut-être du dam des quatre
qui arrivera un jour roi bien aimé jouer
à 5 à 4 à 3 sa peut envoyer h 5 h 4 est
ce qu'il va y avoir h5 non cavaliers c4
menace la dame il ya tour à 6 tours b6
aussi qui peut arriver il ya quand même
des idées qui me semble plus menaçante
pour les noirs tour à 6 et jouer plus
que 18 secondes pour regina et lina qui
va être sous la pression de tourbe et 6
attention h 5 kg on prend ça ne crée pas
de menace pour le moment pour les blancs
la tour arrivant des six le pion en d3
un petit coup d'échecs avec le cavalier
tour ses six tours prend ces deux le
gang qui va remporter cette première
partie en bullet les amis tour c'est si
si si c'est très fort la dame qui prend
et on va prendre probablement en c2 et
tranquillement revenir vers la carte b4
s'assemblent ça semble quasiment fait
pour les noirs il ya aussi tous racistes
possible et ourasi c'est peut-être dame
c5 dont cavaliers b4 s'apprend jécistes
ranger si sedan tours ces deux échecs
intermédiaire s'apprend en a deux il ya
tout qui tombe ya même pas de prison
achète intermédiaires et l'a peut-être
un petit dame à damas six d'un pro b 4
c'est peut-être pas tout à fait tout à
fait finie d'armes français 5 prises
elle prend jamais on achète
intermédiaire donc sur mon tour à 8
maintenant non puis on prend feu prend
des cinq héros est étroit prendre de
haut la la la la la la la la
il y avait foule grand dessein qu'il
fallait faire tour à 8 d'abord
probablement oh là là elle s'échappe et
li na c'est pas fini c'est pas fini les
amis la tour qui vient à eux deux tours
eux qui étaient peut-être pas mauvais
elle est bien quand elle a peu de temps
il y n'a vraiment forte en capacité de
bull est hélas le roi qui monte en c4
latour leroy b 5
or elle est en train de se faire
mystifié cavaliers qui vient à f3 allez
tour des huit tours 17 elle va prendre
ses sept robes et 4 qui va être perdus
et le roi qui va devoir aller à 5 mais
ya pas de bonnes découvertes incroyables
on tour b 2 échecs tout reprend f2i la
tour prend 17 heures pranger 2 mai lyon
qui partait ça aurait fallu faire trois
des cinq plus tôt le pion blanqui par
fou aux cinq j'aime pas du tout parce
que sur ses sept frères y avait trois
des sept peut-être mais les noirs qui
ont quand même les pions qui avance sans
voix à fond leroy qui vient de quatre
façons c'est les noirs qui joue pour la
gagne mais attention ils menacent de
maths en un au nom au nom au nom l a pas
vu la menace de mme attendent un os
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale
aulas comment tu perds ça à comment tu
perds ça la position qui était
complètement gagnante et le math en un
an holl holl holl incroyable les amis
incroyable tours 7
olala c'est quelque chose ça c'est
incroyable arica qui était bien arica
qui était proche de l'emporter et arica
qui a complètement craqué incroyable
incroyable et ça fait mal ça ça fait mal
ça change beaucoup de choses dans ce
match bien évidemment mais c'est
incroyable ce cas la rater oh là là elle
va pouvoir s'en mordre les ongles voilà
c'est quand même elle était vraiment
complètement gagnante à la paf et tours
à huit à l'aller c'est le truc le piège
le machin le fou prend des 5 et là ya
peut-être aussi ce qui était très fort
n'en peut être six accusés sur foot
français 6 avec fous ces six échecs
aussi ça gagner pas tout de suite je
mette leur dise que j'ai l'impression
qu'elle vendanges grave et oui aussi
c'était fini puis on prend 1,6 dame
prend g4 et surtout prend 2,6 pouces et
six échecs
alors évidemment ça joue encore un peu
mais cette position là en bullet c'était
rideau total et là dans la partie
[Musique]
bon elle reste gagnante elle reste
complètement gagnant talent il faut
faire le taf mais quel dommage quel
dommage c'est incroyable la table qui
vient en d1 qu'est ce que c'est que ce
coup d'âme des uns j'ai du mal à suivre
les idées de la joueuse indienne
mais voilà quand même un avantage
matériel énorme tension de passe prendre
qu'à l'étranger 3 mais ça doit être dur
mentalement
la ja le cavac épreuves trois n ya pas
cavalier à katia fou prend à kde
surplomber 4 to b si je crois qu'elle a
raté le pion et là il ya fou prend 1,4
ha ouais non elle a craqué alors elle
reste bien parce que la position était
vraiment écrasante de base mais elle a
donné un pion la cadeaux et en plus se
plonger c'est un pion important puisque
c'est l'option qui pouvait faire j'ai
quatre pour chasser le cavalier elle a
complètement raté qu'un étranger 3 allée
voir food et 4 alors elle est dans le
dur arica elle est dans le très dur
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'elle
était elle était pas loin elle avait le
niveau là pour tenir jeudi je parle à
l'imparfait
parce que ce match me paraît prendre une
très mauvaise tournure pour l'indienne
attendait 3 les il faut réagir
il faut réagir à rick a eu six salles
elle envoie le pion puis on prend il ya
du fou des cinq qui traîne elle devrait
la gagner celle-là quand même avec des
efforts mais ça devrait le faire dame b4
bien joué il ya poussé si ce qui arrive
la tour cas même plus trop de cases en
rollat tour quand même plus de cases en
réalité c'est fini à l'est elle revient
à quatre points c'est dommage parce
qu'elle pourrait être à deux points
franchement elle pouvait gagner la
première partie elle serait revenue à 2
points elle aurait été complètement dans
le match mais c'est pas mort parce
qu'elle joue mieux onduler tariqa al et
le gange reste avec elle le gange reste
avec l'ajout et indiennes et ça peut le
faire aller elle joue cette genre de
karo kann hybrides non elle n'est pas le
pion des cinq à lemé en d6 elle rejoue
ces ouvertures un peu pire que moderne
avec ses six dès 6h cissé a eu 5 elle
met le pion là bas elle a bien géré ses
positions elle a souvent réussi à jouer
vite
elle joue plus
que son adversaire allait arica il faut
revenir il faut recoller c'est
maintenant ou jamais il reste 21 une
minute 22 minutes de match ça fait à peu
près huit partis je pense et en huit
partis quatre points il faut qu'elle
gagne 6 2 il faut marquer immédiat mal
alors les noirs qu une position correcte
cependant les blancs réussi à mettre le
cavalier en c4 à faire la petite
expansion le fou qui va arrivant au 3
mètres la pression peut-être sur le pion
à 7
elle a joué 3 d'abord b 5 qui chasse le
cavalier et puis on prend pions prend
qui va arriver il va y avoir du p5 non
cavaliers 3l revise les casses des 5 et
f5 peut-être fou d'un fouet fils un peu
n'importe quoi faut se développer à 6 et
peut-être on peut jouer pour ces cinq c5
quand même peut-être avec l'idée de
jouer c4 et tant pis pour la case dessin
calais s'est fait par la joueuse
indienne qui menacent d'ailleurs au
passage s'éprend b4 peut-être dans
certaines variantes avec la dame qui
peut être mal placé un coût deux fois
fuite qui peut aussi être dans x fuite
fou prend ses cinq soirées aussi pu être
dans l'idée en cependant elle prend un
éclat dame elle revient à 7 le cavalier
3 qui est cloué roi h1 qui des clous
allez h5 pour jouer peut-être h4 et h3
envoyer du jeu cavaliers h cinq
cavaliers f4 qui va venir allez on va
échanger les cavaliers en d5 ça semble
plus ou moins forcé mais elle réfléchit
peut-être au coup d'après puisque pions
prend c'est le coût qui vient est fou
17-17 la joueuse indienne qui doit
s'activer elle met la pression sur le
pion c mais le fou b4 qui est bien placé
il fait le taff dame eux deux alors où
est ce que veut se diriger la joueuse
arménienne on ne sait pas trop mais f5
jouer maintenant est ce que le coup eux
quatre peut arriver puis on prend lyon
prend fou prend est fou g4 avec une
petite enfilade à s'est pas joué mais
c'était peut-être jouable d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être toujours jouable 4 il ya
cette idée sous g4 à la fin non elle
fait tour c4 elle vient elle se place
peut-être elle veut jouer pour du tour
h4
j'aime bien ce qu'elle fait foi de ya
rien pour le moment elle repart ans et 8
selectour h4 c'était peut-être un peu
ambitieux mais les blancs sont mal
autant des six elles poussent eux 4
contre poux sur pions prend maintenant
peut-être tout reprend avec un fou qui
peut arriver en c6 menacé cependant le
pion des a l'air fort c'est compliqué à
l'est la tour en 1 8
hier il faut prendre le contrôle de
cette colonne eu plus que 7 secondes
pour la joueuse arménienne ça va être
chaud ça va se jouer au couteau les amis
peut-être un petit x 6 intermédiaire
n'entoure trois prises prises et tourer
qui va arriver j'imagine en h3 allait
peut-être du fourrage 6 menace tout
reproche trois échecs
si elle joue vite elle peut y arriver à
les f4 je pense loyal et peut-être
envoyé dame b 8 dames et elle valait ou
1,8 peut-être à l'essai fait peut-être
pour du tour e1 et fouet 4 ça peut
choquer tout re l'un d'entre eux un
fouet f4 ça va mater les amis fous
pranger trois dames f2 damage de maths
c'est fini elle revient à 3 points
arica qui revient à 3 points attention
attention à la joueuse arménienne elle
est en train de se faire remonter à rica
qui maintient la pression qui joue plus
vite
elle joue plus vital mais la pression la
pendule et a réussi à finir
c'est dommage qu'elle ait raté cette
première partie la joueuse indienne
sinon elle serait un seul point de la
joueuse arménienne cependant il reste
encore du temps on n'a pas le temps en
dessous mais aller a dit qu'elle va
juste se concentrer sur ses forces
plutôt que ses faiblesses à c'était dans
l'interview d'avant match la partie
c'est un genre de structure benoni ask à
couleurs opposées on arrive toujours pas
avoir le temps on va retourner sur la
partie cavaliers à 3 pour venir ans et
de pousser bekkat b5 mettre la pression
sur 5 sur le centre
les pions qui vont peut-être partir
après ans à 4 c 5 la joueuse indienne
qui est vraiment à la taxe elle joue
plus vite à la déjà 10 secondes d'avancé
à 3 b 4 l envoyer d'amd de elle va
vraiment préparé b4 au cas où elle aura
toujours tomber elle va y arriver dix
secondes d'avancé elle maintient
vraiment cette pression à la pendule des
4 l envoi maintenant il va leurs pions
prend pions prend des cinq cavaliers
prend au sein qui menace un bep cinq
cavaliers bouche qu'elle prend 1,5 c'est
vraiment la menace les noirs qui vont
devoir réagir
déjà quinze secondes de moins dans cette
partie c'est vraiment une constante à
l'épée 5 qui va quand même partir tête
du cavalier b4 qui peut arriver par la
suite
attention pour la jouer arménienne le
danger est présent
le danger est présent et cavaliers prend
des quatre noms il y avait le cas et qui
protégeait la case de 8
mais attention les pièces sont toutes
attachées les unes entre les autres
il ya toujours cette petite différence
de 14 secondes et peut-être une dame qui
va filer vers la case à 4 attention
quand même aux pions des trois qui
pourraient être menacés
mais damas quatre savais que ça peut
être intéressant cette tour 8 qui peut
être en ligne de mire cavaliers h4 elle
menace de prendre elles menacent
peut-être du cahier des cinq cavaliers
prend suivi de fou prend avec une
pression le long de la colonne le fou
bécade jouer dam des trois j'aime
beaucoup comment joue la joueuse
indienne ici
h3 cavaliers c5 a assez bien joué de la
joueuse a par natcho arménienne qui
réussit à tirer profit de la dame en b3
qui était mal placé dame b 1 revient
protéger le pion fou aux six cavaliers
f3 on réattaque là mais la joueuse
arménienne qui s'est remis en place le
cavalier 17 et le fou protège bien eu
cinq pains tonnant les cavaliers qui
sont bien placés en c5
c'est du jeu de manoeuvre autant ses
revenus c'est à peu près égalité les
deux joueuses à 20 secondes à peu près
cavalier e 4 ça va changer une fois et
remettre un cavalier en c5 peut-être fou
des cinq pour essayer de mettre cavalli
sur des cinq noms fou j'ai 2 elle va
vouloir mettre le cavalier sur des 5 et
maintenir le fou
la tour qui bouge le fou qui vient b2
peut-être que cavaliers des 5 va arriver
n'en fout c'est à elle se réactive
peut-être prépare-t-elle f4 ici f4 qui
va partir non h4 pour le moment dames
attention la tour et la tour pey temps
prise il ya quelque chose sur cette
diagonale fou des deux qui couvre tout
est couvert maintenant et skf 4 va
arriver où il peut être f4 maintenant
cavalier des cinq prises prise elle joue
très vite la joueuse indienne elle elle
a vraiment réalisé son accélération à ce
moment-là f4 qui va partir tôt ou tard à
l'efo faut jouer vite fou b4 elle
maintient la pression de partout fou
prend ses cinq ça échange le fou dessin
qui est plus fort que le fou ces cinq
c'est clair la dame qui va partir en
effroi menace d'un proche 5 allée la
dame qui parent et froid voire même un
pion gk peut-être f100 qui va arriver où
ces six menace le pion ici tourcoing 5
qui va partir non tour de mais attention
le fou ces cinq ne menace pas f2 ici à
d'impro 5 menace damage fuite matt
menace damas huit matches les amis leroy
qui vient d'annoncer cet échec
la dame qui va peut-être venir en des 8
et maintenant comment finir le coup
va s'approcher petit à petit elle ne
réussit pas à mettre la dame où il veut
mais fou des cinq menace peut-être dame
f7 sa menace rien pour le moment
alès peut-être la partie s'échappe et
ici damas huit dames cinq dames g7
plutôt dame g8 à 9,7
elle réussit pas à trouver comment finir
cette histoire et il ya ce pion qui est
mal qui est très mal
alalalala comment elle a raté ça comment
est ce qu'elle a raté sa la joueuse
indienne et elle aurait pu prendre
angers 6 et jouer fou j'ai deux elles
étaient vraiment proches et elle a
craqué à la fin incroyable incroyable
sais c'est dur mais elle perd par elle
perd pas elle reste à trois points de
son adversaire et il reste encore
largement assez de temps pour revenir il
reste quatorze minutes 15 15 minutes on
va dire qu'il reste trois fois 5-5
partie si elle gagne 4 1 elle gagne va
elle revient à égalité donc la joueuse
la joueuse indienne qui est toujours à
portée de fusil et qui a même le droit à
l'erreur encore dans ce match donc elle
joue une trompe offs qui on a vu que
c'était une trompe offs qui est cette
variante où le pion des cinq est sous
pression et en bullet il va falloir
mettre le cavalier e 4 essayer de créer
du jeu avec j'ai cinq tours h 8 h 4 il
va falloir jouer de manière très
pratique ici avec les noirs met son car
ayant eu quatre et on voyait sur le roi
je connais un petit peu parce que je me
suis déjà fait mater à plusieurs
reprises avec les blancs c'est mon
répertoire mais là il faut y aller sans
hésiter sinon tu vas te faire masser
stratégiquement parce que tu as ce pion
en dessin qui est faible et quelques
parts et y ont doublé tu dois en
profiter pour envoyer alors elle mais la
dame aux recettes elles empêchent
cavaliers c5 que va-t-il se passer quand
ils ces cinq quand même au coeur des
français 5 c'est quand même un coup ici
à ne pas négliger parce que ça échange
elles perdent des 5 à la fin il y aura
peut-être tour des huit cette fois ci
c'est la jouer arménienne qui est mieux
à la pendule
alors il va falloir accélérer tour c'est
8 je sais pas trop
il se passer avait peut-être tam ses
trois échecs enfin deux variantes par
non avec une double attaque c'est ce que
j'avais raté donc le pion qui n'était
pas gagné alors pour s'éviter relief 4
maintenant quel est le problème je crois
karaoké mais un problème c'est le pion
des cinq mais ça va échanger
mais c'est sûr pour l'arménienne une
partie nulle salah rapproche forcément
de la victoire finale mais après
l'annulation pas encore signé cependant
la reprise prise reprise des cinq ça va
échanger et elle va même prendre du fou
et c'est plutôt la joueuse arménienne
qui domine un peu avec le duo dame
cavalier est finalement beaucoup de
pions ici sont sur cases noires et donc
le fou de cases noires et pas très
effectifs ici jusqu'à les propositions
progressistes ou c4 mais peut-être une
petite pression mais elle peut chercher
mieux éventuellement alors est ce
qu'elle va prendre
elle aurait pu prendre 6 peut-être et
prendre 17 avec le fou à voir mais elle
se dirige vers etam pranger 5 adam prend
des six attention mais la dame des cinq
à elle est mal à rica avec les noirs
arica l'acquis et attention elle
pourrait passer par la fenêtre elle peut
passer par la fenêtre l'a déjà on peut
tout prendre un f4 il ya du cavalier six
tirs aude cave a lieu quatre aussi
jouable fou qui est mal placée c'est une
quasi balle de match dame prend bessette
ici jouable gagnerez un pion à arica qui
est en train de craquer arica qui est en
train de craquer dans une partie qui
durant plus aller d'am-dam pour venir en
d1 sur échec mais iliad à mes fins d'un
mail 5 bien joué elle rentre pas dans la
gueule du loup
elle se prépare la dame qui vient quand
même en f3 mesdames français 7 c sur
échec aux états match cet échec gagner
le match directement parce que ça
regagner la dame sur fourchette elle n'a
pas vu mais elle abandonne quand même et
il ya de nouveaux plus 4 avec quatre
parties à jouer maxi ça semble difficile
pour harry qu'à arica qui a craqué
vraiment elle n'était pas si loin et
quand même quand il yn'a a remis les
petits coups d'accélérateur ça fait la
différence
dur pour arica j'ai du mal à voir dans
quel monde elle remonte à la quand même
beaucoup vendangé tout ce match elle a
fait deux cadeaux dans les ouvertures on
s'en rappelle
plus tôt elle a donné deux parties elle
a raté deux occasions du let
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est en train
de payer les occasions ratées et les
cadeaux et c'est vraiment dommage parce
qu'elle avait peut-être le niveau mais
un petit peu comme contre katia
danielyan qui gardent à rennes toutes
petites limites
c'est cette toute petite différence qui
fait qu'elle tient le match et qu'elle
va probablement l'emporter alors cette
partie qui n'est pas encore fait mais en
plus ces partis qui durent longtemps
beaucoup de coups sont jouées donc quand
je vous dis trois minutes par partie
je suis même un petit peu optimiste pour
la joueuse indienne
parce qu'on est souvent plutôt autour
des quatre minutes dans ce match deux
minutes de jeu et une soixantaine de
coups ça fait plutôt quatre minutes que
les partis sont serrés mais allez on va
se lancer à fond dans cette partie on
voit que les blancs envoie le va-tout
elle veut peut-être mettre le pion à f/5
est complètement enfermé le fou g6 qui
pourraient se retrouver sans case
elle jouera peut-être quand même avec
petit roquet ce que les noirs vont jouer
gros rock c'est une possibilité à elle
peut partir pour grand roque jouer des
rocs opposés et dire voilà si tu prends
le pion aux 5 j'ai reculé sur f5 fois h7
je chasserai t pion par g6 et je
reviendrai quelque part contre-attaqué à
l'est le roi arica qui prend tous les
risques dans cette partie mais est-ce
que ça va payer j'en suis pas sûr un
coup comme dame b4 ici peut être gênant
h5 cavalli g4 est gênant aussi elle
vient un peu taper sur le pion aux trois
dames b4 ici tout à fait jouable pour
protéger l férois b8 elle laisse le
laisse j'ai quatre ans prises franges et
quatre sur le projet quatre dames
pranger 4 qui va être joué et d'amd de
elle vient s'introduire et menacé le
pion ces deux tours c'est un qui le
défend dame prend à deux qui gagne le
pion cavaliers f3 f6 est maintenant sûr
j'ai six fours g8 sont fous pas
peut-être revivre par la suite alors des
quatre on imagine quatre ferme le jeu le
cavalier qui revient en d2 peut-être un
petit coup de damas cinq pour partir
avec la dame ou peut-être juste fou g8
pour activer la tour sur la colonne h
elle prend
j'ai 5 c'est faisable aussi et dames b2
pour revenir vers la case c3 et menacé
le cavalier et le pion à eux trois mais
la dame qui avions f406 est qu les
blancs qui semble sous contrôle mais les
noirs qui vont jouer pour du faux f7
tourache cinq tours h 8 s'est pas encore
fait le fou qui naviguent la tour qui
vient en a un oeil avait dame prend ici
un il y avait d'un point incroyable
la tour en 1 qui a été ratée mais pour
le moment ça va encore pour les noirs
qui vont faire tour h4 et tourache 8
quoique ya dame prend g7 et tourache
fuite ya pas de menace ici il n'y a pas
de menaces il faut quand même tenté dame
prend 17 touché 4 kg trois dames prendre
trois tours j'ai quatre échecs tg3 dame
prend 2,3 dams et 7 pour couvrir non
tout reprend assistions progressiste
dame france et 6 mais ça m'a pas l'air
d'être si puissant qu'est ce qu'elle
fait à riquet elle aurait pu tout
défendre avec dams et 7
il n'y avait pas de menace elle prend le
père pète et c'est une décision plus
qu'étrange parce qu'il reste plus que
sept minutes 47 les mecs et je peux vous
annoncer que c'est mathématiquement
terminée donc à rica qui a qui pouvait
peut-être pas gagné gagné la partie 1
mais bon elle a juste elle a juste donné
le match là il y aura maximum trois
parties et à mon avis c'est complètement
finie donc on va un peu se calmer sur
les commentaires parce que on va pas
faire croire à un faux suspense
le match là en plus nous on a un petit
décalage par rapport à la partie qu'on a
et le temps donc il reste plutôt sept
minutes donc ouais serveurs mais trois
parties c max c'est ça la rs4 loteries
reste une
et quoique quoique quoique si elle gagne
vite peut-être que il ya moyen de
moyenner mais ça paraît quand même
compliqué ça paraît quand même très
compliqué pour pour la joueuse indienne
qui doit envoyer sur le roi mais c'est
vrai qu'à la passe est envoyé sur le roi
dans lappartient à propos ce qu'avec les
noirs
elle a raté des deux occasions au début
dû au début du de la section du lait
est c'est vrai que ça semble difficile
de l'avoir gagné mais allez on peut y
croire en cas de déconnexion peut être
effectivement quand on dit dans le chatt
d'elina ou si la joueuse indienne joue
vraiment vite et qu'elle gagne en
gardant beaucoup de temps à la pendule
c'est encore faisable mais il va falloir
qu'elle qu'elle fasse du prêt move dupré
move dupré move du tour allez on envoie
tour g8 on envoie aux 5
on envoie f4 on attaque le cavalier et
et on gagne on gagne cette partie vite
faits allégués h 5 1 et tours g8 vite
dame j'ai cinq tours g8 aller il faut
envoyer
il faut espérer qu'elle voit pas le
matin en a il faut faire quelque chose
il faut gagner le match et il faut
gagner les partis rapidement sinon ça va
pas le faire aller f4 l on voit enfin
cavaliers f3 probablement va être joué
ici et c'est vrai qu'elle est mal autant
il n'a de nouveau elle rame un petit peu
qu avec adam 5 et le fou qui va arriver
à f/5 la tour en 1 8
et à mon avis ça devrait le faire à
linac essaye de rentrer dans une finale
façon pour danielian ici il faut pas
forcément gagné 1 il faut surtout joué
beaucoup de coups et sexy à la lucidité
elle peut faire durer la partie si ray
si si elle la joue pardon à la grille
tchouk et quelques joutes ou tempo elle
tait peux te faire durer une partie bien
plus de trois minutes en réalité mais il
faut jouer tempo et elle va tomber
incroyable incroyable les amis le match
qu'on pensait terminer et peut-être pas
terminée terminé parce que danielyan est
tombé incroyable il reste 5 minutes
alors est ce qu'elle peut gagner une
partie des parts ya sa part est toujours
très difficile de voir comment trois
parties peuvent être joués ici mais
c'est étonnant parce que si elle avait
joué plus vite
elle aurait pu faire au moins une
trentaine de secondes allez on va dire
20 envahir 20 couverts seconde qu'un
second alors il faut faire jouer 35 40
secondes de plus et là ça en était
complètement fini mais allez si elle
continue à tomber comme ça
tout peut encore arriver par contre il
faut carrick ajoute ou tempo
il faut vraiment jouer tempo tempo tempo
allez on va essayer de faire peut-être
cavaliers 5 g
atf quatre peut-être envoyé pour le
moment à quatre c'est un peu trop
stratégique cette histoire-là faut
vraiment y aller la faune envoyé faut
envoyer arica t'as plus le choix elle a
déjà pris le père pète ce qui était
vraiment une décision incroyable
tout à l'heure il faut y aller à les
dames des deux dames ici qu'à aider si
c'est bien jouer envoyez f40 façon il
faut gagner vite il ya cavaliers c4 et
prend à 500 avec stratégiquement c'est
gagnant mais c'est une partie qui va
durer malheureusement et ça c'est pas ce
qu'on veut quand on est supporters du
gange
parce que il reste 4 minutes et il
faudrait gagner cette partie là et la
prochaine dans le temps imparti
c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment quatre
minutes pour en gagner 2 pour s'offrir
pour s'offrir la troisième partie et
même si cela continue et c'est vrai
qu'il ya au moins 40 secondes en rab
pour elina si elles jouent le jeu de la
pendule qu'elle devrait apparemment joué
donc c'est vrai qu'il va falloir très
longtemps normalement pour la gagner
plus la partie dure de coûts plus vous
avez de rajout d'une seconde et plus
vous avez de rajout d'une seconde
évidemment plus votre adversaire peuvent
faire couler le temps et la tour qui
arrive ici ont des deux je pense que les
blancs sont tout de même très bien il ya
sac un peu fait bien ça qui peut être
faible
elle fait ses quatre aux alentours des 8
va être jouée par les noirs et elle va
vouloir peut-être tour ces deux
cavaliers des cinq bien joué elle
attaque la tour d2 à l'attack la dame ça
c'était un petit piège
ça c'est fait qu' on prend dame prend
des deux et elle va sûrement prendre
ces quatre plus tôt et ça va partir
pourquoi mais non là c'est une qualité
plus c'est complètement gagnant mais le
temps qui tourne à l'est je jette un
coup d'oeil à rs 2 minutes 40 comme gégé
le petit lac j'avais plutôt 2 minutes 15
2 minutes 20 on va dire à il faudrait
gagner vraiment vite
il faut tout donner pour gagner dans les
30 secondes à venir espérer espérer un
miracle et fo qui va venir en e2 que
vont faire les blancs peut-être damas
trois pour tours à cette damas dams est
allé faut mater vite faut y aller et
côté li na faut juste blindés essayer de
jouer le plus de coups possibles quitte
même à donner la dame normalement de son
côté elle s'en contrefiche il faut juste
jouer des coups côté noirs les blancs
qui envoie h 4 h 5
peut-être fois h3 qui peut venir pour
essayer d'introduire le fond f5 et mais
la dame en trois tours b3 très bien joué
mais tour ces trois coups on prend b2
tour à trois dames des six tours fc est
allé ce que les blancs vont réussir à
les mater le fou qu'il y en a cinq
la partie qui est très serré autour
d'eux c'est même plus sûr que les blancs
soit vraiment mieux
tourcoing f2 qui va arriver non dame ces
six cavaliers e6 elle défend et tout
reprend f2 qui rôdent g4 saddam g3 mais
h5
elle est noire qui se défendent très
bien ces trois pions prend ses deux
pions prend dame prend 17 ici tout
reprend 17 et c'est un dan ans elle
prend g2 qui sert à rien et cavaliers g5
qui est très bizarre elle a pas vus dame
prend 17 en fait est là il va y avoir ou
l'a pas fait échec en h7
c'était aussi raté de la part des blancs
et il va y avoir un père pète il ya eu
déjà eu des vendanges et deux côtés
perpète
et finalement le match qu'ils aient
gagné mais ça a vendangé une nouvelle
fois côté arica et lao de toute façon le
match qui était terminée elle aurait pas
pu gagner en 50 secondes et donc pas de
regret pas pas de regret pas de regret
sur cette partie en tout cas mais
mais harry cas je trouve qu'il ya plus
ou moins dominé le match mais qui a été
un peu juste dans les positions
gagnantes
dommage en tout cas pour elle qui ne
verra pas la finale et donc et lina qui
à la surprise générale sort des
qualifications élimine katyal haguenau
élimine arica et jouera là la vainqueur
du match kosteniuk gunino
comme vous le voyez le 27 juin donc
jeudi prochain à 18 heures ce sera la
grande finale du speech s féminin prise
est roi il va du grand roque ici on va
voir peut-être grand roque pour les
noirs mais de toute façon le match est
terminé les amis donc c'est difficile de
ceux de s'extasier devant devant ces
parties de bullet je préfère discuter
avec vous deux petites minutes
je trouve qu'il a bien plus fort toi est
ce que oui ou non est favorite pour le
match de dimanche contre kosteniuk dur à
dire moi je mettrais kosteniuk favorite
personnellement après on verra
tout est possible mais pour moi
kosteniuk est favorite
merci que smarteo vous on fait ce qu'on
peut quand on commente un aujourd'hui je
te cache pas que le match n'a pas été
très passionnant notamment parce que ça
manque un peu de suspens et que les
partis dont le manque de suspense et les
partis qui étaient pas vraiment d'en
haut niveau non plus hein on va pas se
mentir on dit la vérité les amis c'est
pas l'objectif de vous faire croire à un
spectacle incroyable quand il y en a pas
mais pour moi et li na sera favorite de
la finale sur ce qu'elle a montré ça
m'étonnerait pas de voir la joueuse
arménienne l'emporter dans le tournoi ça
m'étonnerait pas du tout parce que je
joue ensuite non je vais jour et demain
soir demain je finis mon déménagement
comme geste et le dr
les strings ici normalement c'est un
grand plaisir de stream et pour vous de
l'appartement le plus petit du monde ce
sera un plaisir de ce crime et pour vous
d'un appartement plus grand ce qui
offrira plus de possibilités
évidemment ce sera beaucoup plus sympa
c'était en tout cas un plaisir et c'est
une page qui se tourne carrément une
page qui se tourne et li na qui a
peut-être perdre la dernière
donc j'en verrai un raid à la fin du
match je mettrai une page de pub et jean
bérard est sur la chaîne officielle du
gain fonds va encore plus loin -
utiliser le fonds vert a été utilisé en
fait mais peut-être que tu ne regardes
pas aller les best-of peut-être et donc
arica killian la dernière mais s'est
finie sur +2 ouais j'ai produit de fumer
là partent quand quand j'aurai tout
envoyer le bordel je filmerai vous
verrez à quel point ces petits
j'éprouvais si tu as vu savait à quoi
servait le fonds vert du goût avec le
montage 15-13 ouais donc victoire de li
na qui gagne ce match vrai qu'un stress
va écouter ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vous envoyer en raid
ouais plus de spa énorme quand on voit
les erreurs après l'hymne aurait
peut-être un peu mieux joué si l'autre
avait moins bien jouer quoi donc les
mecs merci d'avoir suivi demain soir
l'aréna king pourrait suivre avec points
ou avec mvele qui qui jouera l'aréna
aussi et donc bah écoutez je vous mets
le raid et puis on se retrouve on se
retrouve demain s'arrête dans la chaîne
de chess comme si vous voulez suivre les
interviews des deux joueuses problème
dalkeith trimera l'aréna qui streamera
l'aréna aussi et tu va piquer ma
première page c'est pas grave allez hop
c'est parti vous envoient leur aide et
je vous dis à demain
ciao les mecs
[Musique]